I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道今年才刚开始，但我们已经在讨论夏天的家庭旅行了。你知道我们很喜欢用爱彼迎。我知道这点。嗯，我们喜欢有个厨房，我喜欢早上穿着长袍走出去喝杯茶，正如你所说，珍娜，我喜欢长跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去那儿看望他，他给我们订了一个非常棒的爱彼迎，全家人一起住。这样我们就能散开，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会觉得就像在家一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I do know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right. Yeah. Everyone, we're ladies who Airbnb, I guess. For your next
尽管你在一个不同的城市。天哪，我才不想和我的整个家族睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了去住好莱坞大酒店了。对，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。对，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，真正的冰箱。你知道的，我喜欢吃零食。我确实知道这点。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我就要它们就在那儿。没错。对。各位，我想我们都是爱彼迎的女性。对于你的下一次
adventure, for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories.
冒险，对于你的下一次假期，也许可以考虑一下爱彼迎。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多VFF的故事，带你更深入地了解《办公室》的世界。
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We have a special guest today in the studio. Yes. It's my possible cousin. Yes. Clark Duke.
我们是办公室女郎 6.0。你好。欢迎来到《办公室女郎 6.0》。今天我们在演播室有一位特邀嘉宾。是的。我可能表亲。是的。克拉克·杜克。
That's right. Joining us cousin, Clark Duke. That's right. Joining us today is Clark Duke, who played Clark Green on The Office. He joined the show in season nine, episode one, titled New Guys. Clark Green is the new customer service representative at the Scranton branch of Dunder Mifflin. And yes, Angela, a possible cousin of yours.
没错。欢迎我们的表亲，克拉克·杜克。没错，今天加入我们的是克拉克·杜克，他在《办公室》中饰演克拉克·格林。他在第九季第一集《新家伙》中加入该剧。克拉克·格林是邓德米夫林公司斯克兰顿分公司的新客户服务代表。是的，安吉拉，还是你的远房表亲。
We'll get to that with him. We did speak about it in more detail. I love this little tangent. But first, here's a little bit about Clark Duke. He is an actor, writer, director, producer. He is originally from Arkansas. How cool is this? When he was in college, Clark created, wrote, directed, and produced the web series Clark and Michael with his friend Michael Cera, in which he plays a fictional version of himself. In our conversation with him, he talks a lot about how that project that he did, that was his college thesis, actually, really informed his role on The Office. Yes.
我们等会会和他聊到这个。我们确实详细谈过这件事。我喜欢这个小插曲。但首先，让我们简单了解一下克拉克·杜克。他是一名演员、编剧、导演、制片人。他来自阿肯色州。这有多酷？当他在上大学时，克拉克和他的朋友迈克尔·塞拉一起创作、编剧、导演并制作了网络剧《克拉克和迈克尔》，他在剧中饰演虚构的自己。在我们与他的对话中，他谈了很多关于他做的那个项目——实际上那是他的大学毕业论文——如何真正影响了他在《办公室》中的角色。是的。
Yeah. Now listen, you guys might know Clark from his other acting roles in Greek, Superbad, Sex Drive, A Thousand Words, Kick Ass 1 and 2, Hot Tub Time Machine 1 and 2, Bad Moms, Identity Theft, and I'm Dying Up Here, which he stars in with Jake Lacey. He is also a writer and director.
听着，你们可能通过克拉克的其他演艺作品认识他，比如《希腊之歌》、《超级坏》、《性爱驾驶》、《千言万语》、《海扁王1和2》、《热浴盆时光机1和2》、《坏妈妈》、《身份窃盗》，以及他与杰克·莱西联袂主演的《我正在消亡》。他同时也是一名编剧和导演。
He wrote, directed, and starred in the feature film Arkansas and the upcoming Strange Hold, which reunites him with Jake Lacey. And of course, we all know him from The Office and he joins us in the studio today to talk about his time on The Office, plus so much more. But before we play his interview, I think we need to revisit some fan favorite moments
他自编自导并主演了故事片《阿肯色州》以及即将上映的《Strange Hold》，该片让他与杰克·莱西再度合作。当然，我们都通过《办公室》认识了他，今天他来到我们的演播室，和我们聊聊他在《办公室》的时光，以及更多精彩内容。但在我们播放对他的采访之前，我想我们需要重温一些粉丝最爱的克拉克
of Clark. According to fans, this is one of the best one-liners Clark ever said on the show. It's from Moving On, part one. Man, that seemed like it, but this really helped. So thank you. I'll give you $100 to wear that sweater to work tomorrow. Oh yeah. Oh yeah, that was so funny.
的高光时刻。据粉丝称，这是克拉克在剧中说过最棒的俏皮话之一。它出自《向前看》第一集。天哪，看起来是这样，但这真的帮了大忙。所以谢谢你。我给你100美元，让你明天穿着那件毛衣去上班。哦，对。哦，对，那太搞笑了。
That's right. This is when Andy is starting to put together that maybe Aaron is seeing someone. Yes, and maybe she gave his sweater to this new person who is Pete. Yeah. Yes. Well, other fans wrote in to say that they love this bit of Clark sass to Jim in Live in the Dream. We talk about this in our interview with Clark.
没错。这是安迪开始察觉到艾琳可能在约会某人。是的，而且她可能把他的毛衣送给了这个新的人，也就是皮特。是啊。是的。嗯，其他粉丝写信说他们喜欢克拉克在《活在梦中》里对吉姆的这番傲慢言论。我们在对克拉克的采访中谈到了这一点。
Here it is. Oh, Clark. I'm actually here today. Surprise! So I was wondering if maybe I could have my desk back. Right. Yeah, but you know, I've actually been working pretty hard here on a daily basis, so I kind of feel like I've earned this.
就是这个。哦，克拉克。我今天其实来了。惊不惊喜！所以我一直在想，也许我能拿回我的办公桌？对。是的，但你知道，我其实每天都在这里工作得挺努力的，所以我有点觉得我赢得了这个位子。
I mean, you know? Totally have. You have earned it. But maybe I could be with my wife. That's kind of the whole reason why I'm here. Right. Well, I'm here to sell paper. Burn.
我是说，你知道吗？完全赢得了。你确实配得上。但也许我可以和我的妻子在一起。这基本上是我来这里的全部原因。对。好吧，我是来卖纸的。漂亮的一击。
Yes, that is my personal fave. Well, we both have a lot of favorite Clark moments and it's so fun to talk to him about it all. Yes, I think he also may have my favorite call sheet questions answers yet. They were- Like, stay tuned for his call sheet questions is all I have to say. Absolutely. I mean call sheet question number one. Wowzers.
是的，那是我的个人最爱。嗯，我们俩都有很多最喜欢的克拉克时刻，和他聊起这一切真的太有趣了。是的，我觉得他可能也给出了我见过的最棒的通告单问题回答。它们是——敬请期待他的通告单回答，这就是我想说的。绝对的。我是说通告单问题第一号。哇塞。
Wowzers. Well, let's take a break and when we come back, it's our interview with Clark Duke. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. And this month, BetterHelp is giving you the biggest discount on starting therapy that they have ever offered on our show, with 90% off your first week. So here's how it works. With BetterHelp, you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions, and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible and with online therapy you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over
哇塞。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后就是对克拉克·杜克的采访。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。本月，BetterHelp为你提供他们在我们的节目中从未提供过的最高疗程折扣，你的第一周可享90%的优惠。以下是它的运作方式。通过BetterHelp，你可以为每周的课程支付固定费用，这将在费用和时间上为你省下一大笔钱，因为心理治疗应该是触手可及的，通过在线治疗，你可以以合理的价格获得高质量的护理。并且拥有超过
30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Your well-being is worth it. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 90% off your I'm Jordan Robinson, host of the new podcast, The Women's Hoop Show. Each episode, I'll be joined by a rotating group of women's basketball experts to talk
3万名治疗师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过500万名提供过服务。而且它很方便。你只需点击一个按钮就可以参加课程，这有助于你将心理治疗融入繁忙的生活中。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。你的身心健康绝对值得。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜线office ladies，即可享受90%的我是乔丹·罗宾逊，全新播客《女子篮球秀》的主持人。在每一集中，我都会和轮流做客的女篮专家小组一起谈论
WNBA, college hoops, the new Unrivaled League, and the shifting landscape of the sport. The game is growing and so are we. Listen to and follow the Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey podcast available now for free on the Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcasts. ["Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey"] ["Women's Hoop Show and Odyssey"] Hello! Hi! How are you? I'm great! Welcome! Thank you! It's so great to be here. It's nice to see you guys. It's really nice to see you. Besides the Christmas cards. I know.
WNBA、大学篮球、全新的无敌联盟，以及这项运动不断变化的格局。这项比赛在成长，我们也是。收听并关注《女子篮球秀》和奥德赛播客，现已在奥德赛应用程序或您获取播客的任何地方免费提供。["女子篮球秀和奥德赛"] ["女子篮球秀和奥德赛"] 你好！嗨！你好吗？我很好！欢迎！谢谢！很高兴来到这里。很高兴见到你们。真的很高兴见到你们。除了圣诞卡之外。我知道。
Yeah. I love getting your mom's Christmas card. We haven't done one in a while. It's because it's like you got to plan it in like June. I June. But I got one. I had it. I taped it up in the dining room. Walked past your family. But we didn't do like a full shoot, you know? No. Like a planned photo shoot. Yeah, but you need to tell your mom she needs to get back on it because she slacked off last year. I agree. Could you guys please share with people how this Christmas card thing came about. It's because you're maybe like distant relatives, right? This is our joke. Okay, so we were chatting on set one day and I was like, wait a second.
是啊。我很喜欢收到你妈妈寄的圣诞卡。我们有一阵子没做了。那是因为你得在比如六月份就开始规划。我六月份。但我收到了一张。我有。我把它贴在餐厅里了。走过你的家人。但我们没有拍那种完整的照片，你知道吗？没有。比如那种计划好的照片拍摄。是的，但你得告诉你妈妈她得重新开始做这事了，因为她去年偷懒了。我同意。你们能跟大伙分享一下这个圣诞卡是怎么来的吗？这是因为你们可能是远亲，对吧？这是我们的笑话。好吧，所以有一天我们在片场聊天，然后我说，等等。
We have a lot of the same family names. And then you're from North Carolina. There's this lore that my family's from North Carolina. I mean, are we related? Well, you probably are if they're actually from North Carolina, like confirmed, yeah. I don't know, guys. I could be sitting across from my eighth cousin
我们有很多相同的家族姓氏。然后你是来自北卡罗来纳州的。有个传言说我的家族来自北卡罗来纳州。我的意思是，我们有亲戚关系吗？嗯，如果他们真的来自北卡罗来纳州的话，那可能确实有，已经证实了，是的。我不知道，伙计们。我可能正坐在我的第八代表亲对面
twice removed. Well, you're family enough to send a Christmas card every year, even after all these years. I thought at first you meant like the history of like Christmas cards in general, and I was like, I have no idea. I know, I wanna Google that. I know I want to Google that. I know.
隔了两次。嗯，你们的亲戚关系已经亲密到每年都寄一张圣诞卡了，即使过了这么多年。我一开始以为你指的是圣诞卡的历史之类的，然后我想，我完全不知道。我知道，我想去谷歌一下。我知道我想去谷歌一下。我知道。
You've put that in my head. Yeah. All right, cousin, let's get to it. Let's kick things off with the question we ask everybody. The first question, how did you get your job on the office? So I met Greg Daniels. I forget what year, it was a few, at least a couple years or a few years before I got on The Office and he was making a different show.
你把这个想法植入我脑海了。好的，表亲，我们开始吧。让我们从我们问每个人的问题开始。第一个问题，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？所以我遇到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我忘了那是哪一年了，那是好几年，至少在我加入《办公室》的前几年或几年，当时他在制作另一部剧。
And I don't remember if the show, anyway, I ended up not doing that show because it just wasn't for me. But I like Greg so much and I like the office very much, obviously. And then just kind of years later, out of the blue, I got my manager called me one day and said like, basically like Greg wanted to know if he would be interested in like joining the cast of The Office. And I was like, well, yeah, that would be great. Because I mean, for me, I went to film school at Loyola Marymount out here in LA. And my thesis project was an mockumentary called Clark and Michael, me and Michael Cera. And our main influence was two things.
我不记得那部剧是不是，总之，我最后没有演那部剧，因为它不太适合我。但我非常喜欢格雷格，而且很明显我非常喜欢《办公室》。然后几年后，毫无预兆地，有一天我接到经纪人的电话，基本上就是格雷格想知道我是否有兴趣加入《办公室》的演员阵容。我就想，好吧，那太棒了。因为对我来说，我在洛杉矶这里的洛约拉玛丽茅特大学读电影学院。我的毕业设计是一个名为《克拉克和迈克尔》的伪纪录片，我和迈克尔·塞拉一起拍的。我们的主要灵感来源是两件事。
It was this thing called Stella with David Wayne and Michael Showalter. And the other thing was the British office. I mean, mainly the British office. So I had been a huge fan since the British office. So for me, it felt very like full circle and neat for me personally, just to like get to be on the show. Yeah, so that was it.
一个是戴维·韦恩和迈克尔·绍瓦尔特创作的名为《斯特拉》的东西。另一个是英国版的《办公室》。我是说，主要是英国版的《办公室》。所以自从英国版《办公室》以来，我一直是它的超级粉丝。所以对我自己来说，能够参演这部剧感觉非常圆满而且很有意义。是的，就是这样。
I mean, it was not a lot of deliberation or anything. I was like, of course, I would love to be on the office. What a great phone call to get to be on the show. Yeah, so that was it. I mean, it was not a lot of deliberation or anything. I was like, of course, I would love to be on The Office. What a great phone call to get. Yeah, yeah. I haven't had a phone call that good in a while. Yeah, that was a good one. How did they talk to you about the character you would be playing?
我是说，没有太多的深思熟虑什么的。我就想，当然，我很乐意加入《办公室》。能接到参演这部剧的电话太棒了。是的，就是这样。我是说，没有太多的深思熟虑什么的。我就想，当然，我很乐意加入《办公室》。能接到参演这部剧的电话太棒了。对，对。我已经很久没接到过这么棒的电话了。对，那真是一个好电话。他们是怎么跟你谈论你要扮演的角色的？
Were you part of the development of this character? Did they tell you at the time, oh, you're gonna be paired with this other new guy? Did they give you any of those details? I knew we were going to be paired with another new guy. As far as like, you know, the characterization, I don't recall there being a lot of specific notes about like how to play. I mean, I think it was sort of like... Like do your thing?
你参与了这个角色的开发吗？他们当时有没有告诉你，哦，你要和另一个新家伙搭档？他们有没有透露任何这些细节？我知道我们要和另一个新家伙搭档。至于，你知道的，角色塑造方面，我不记得有很多关于如何表演的具体意见。我的意思是，我觉得它有点像……就像做你自己？
Yeah, I think it was sort of like acting as casting, you know what I mean? I think it was just like kind of me. And I mean that was why, you know, because a lot of people said like, oh, like did they want to name you Clark? And like that was my idea and it was sort of also in the back of my head too, like maybe this is Clark from Clark and Michael, like like ten years later or whatever. Yeah. And I mean that was that was just like the lore in my head, like not like you know anybody else. But I also thought it was fun you know because there's a lot of people on the show that use their real name. Right. I don't think there was a lot of specific like you need to
对，我觉得有点像本色出演，你知道我的意思吗？我觉得就有点像我本人。这就是为什么，你知道的，因为很多人说，哦，他们是想给你起名叫克拉克吗？那是我的主意，而且我脑海深处也想过，也许这就是《克拉克和迈克尔》里的那个克拉克，比如十年后或者别的什么。是的。我的意思是，这只是我脑海中的背景设定，并不是说你知道其他任何人。但我也觉得这很有趣，你知道的，因为剧里有很多人用他们自己的真名。没错。我觉得没有什么具体的要求，比如你需要
play it like this. It was more like I think they kind of just wanted my you know me whatever that is. I have one more like follow-up question to your casting process. At the time, weren't you told that this could possibly be the beginning of a spin-off show? Like that you and Jake were gonna be the two new guys for the final season of The Office and that your characters might carry the torch into the next iteration? Yeah, that was my understanding of it.
这样表演。更像是我觉得他们大概只是想要我的，你知道的，我本人，不管那是什么。关于你的选角过程，我还有一个后续问题。当时，难道没人告诉你这可能是一部衍生剧的开始吗？比如你和杰克将成为《办公室》最终季的两个新家伙，你们的角色可能会把火炬传递到下一个版本中？是的，我是这么理解的。
Not even like a spinoff, but like ER, where it was like just new cast, some of the existing cast would stay and then you'd bring in like new people too and kind of be a mix. But yeah, that was my understanding of it, was it would be, yeah, like ER, and they would keep the show going.
甚至不是像衍生剧那样，而是像《急诊室的故事》那样，就是全新的演员阵容，一些现有的演员会留下来，然后你也会带入一些新人，有点像个混合体。但是是的，我的理解就是这样，它会是，是的，就像《急诊室的故事》一样，他们会让这部剧继续播下去。
So I was looking forward to being on the show for like years, potentially. I remember when we watched the finale there was all of this extra footage, right you and With Dakota Johnson. Yeah, and like you were gonna be each other's love interest We shot like this whole I remember for like a week or two. Yeah, we shot all this stuff There's tons of footage. Yeah all gone. I wonder if they'll put it back in the superfan episode Maybe maybe well It was so funny too because I'm I saw like or somebody sent it to me on Instagram a while ago when she was doing The press for a for a movie she kept talking about how
所以我很期待能在这部剧里演上几年，潜在地。我记得当我们看大结局时，有所有这些额外的镜头，对吧，你和达科塔·约翰逊。是的，你们本来是彼此的感情对象。我们拍了整个，我记得持续了一两周。是的，我们拍了所有这些东西。有大量的镜头。是的，全都没了。不知道他们会不会把它放回超级粉丝版里？也许，也许，好吧。
Like oh that was like the worst week of my life like these I sit around and then they never use any of it Which made me laugh really hard. Well Dakota it might be in the super fan. It might come back. It might live again But yeah, but that was um Yeah, that was my understanding of it in my hope you know to be honest well we have a fan question great for you from Joanne Kay in Cape May New Jersey she says what was it like coming into the office so late in the run it seems like it would feel like being a transfer student senior year it was a little bit like that but you know the thing is it wasn't hard because it was such a like smooth running machine.
太滑稽了，因为我看到——或者有人前一阵子在Instagram上发给我在她为一部电影做宣传时，她一直在说
You know you're joining like this thing that that like runs like a clock at that point. And everybody was so nice. And I will say you guys specifically you two were the nicest of and I'm not just saying that because of the podcast. You guys were very sweet to me. I always appreciate it. We were very excited when you and Jay joined the show. When we spoke with him, we told him that it was like,
哦，那简直是我生命中最糟糕的一周——这些人让我干坐着，然后他们从来不用任何这些镜头——这让我笑得前仰后合。好吧，达科塔，它可能会出现在超级粉丝版里。它可能会回归。它可能会重获新生。但是是的，但是那是，是的，那是我的理解，也是我的希望，老实说。好吧，我们有一个来自新泽西州开普梅的乔安·K的粉丝提问，非常适合你。她说，在剧集播出这么晚的时候加入《办公室》是什么感觉？感觉好像有点像高三时转学去的学生。确实有点那种感觉，但你知道吗，并不难，因为它是一台运转如此顺畅的机器。
we needed new people. Yeah. You guys were so funny. You were so nice. You were so talented. You had new stories to tell. I think that's the thing too. We were like a family where as soon as John started doing a bit, I'm like, that's the thing too is like we were like a family where like as soon as John started
你知道你加入的是一个在那个阶段像时钟一样精准运转的东西。每个人都超级好。而且我要说，你们俩，特别是你们俩，是里面最好的人，我可不是为了播客才这么说的。你们对我非常温柔。我一直很感激。当你和杰克加入剧组时，我们非常兴奋。当我们采访他时，我们告诉他，
doing a bit I'm like that's his boom operator bit. We've seen it for nine years. It's still funny but you guys came in with all this new energy. Well it is very much like a family because I mean when you you know just from doing so much tv over the years over the course of my life like you know you spend more time with those people on set than you do your actual family in a lot of cases, you know, for like six or nine months a year, like 12 or 14 hours a day. It is really like a family atmosphere. So yeah, it was sort of, I thought it was going to be intimidating, but it ended up being kind of just a pleasure because it was just so easy.
我们需要新面孔。是的。你们太搞笑了。你们太友好了。你们太有才了。你们有新的故事要讲。我觉得这也是那点，我们就像一个大家庭，一旦约翰开始表演一个小段子，我就觉得，这也是那点，我们就像一个大家庭，一旦约翰开始
And everybody could go, you know? Like I remember, I think the first scene I ever shot was it was me and Rain at like the snack machine. Oh my gosh. And it was sort of like a feeling out thing of like, cause I wasn't sure how much, you know, like how much improv to do. Like you didn't want to show up and be like. That guy, right?
表演一个小段子，我就觉得，那是他的诈杆员段子。我们已经看了九年了。它依然很好笑，但你们带着全新的能量加入了进来。嗯，它确实很像一个大家庭，因为我的意思是，当你在——你知道的，仅仅是因为多年来在我的生活中拍了那么多的电视剧——你知道的，你在片场和那些人在一起的时间，在很多情况下比你和真正的家人在一起的时间还要多，你知道的，一年有六到九个月，一天有12或14个小时。这真的很像一个家庭的氛围。所以，是的，我一开始以为这会让人畏惧，但结果却成了一种享受，因为它实在是太轻松了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You don't want to like come in super hot. Be like, I got jokes guys. I know you've won some Emmys, but hey, here's my stuff. And you know, like, it never needed a lot of improv because the scripts were so good too. But I remember, you know, being a little bit nervous like that day. But then it was just, you know, Rain is so funny
每个人都能跟上节奏，你知道吗？就像我记得，我拍的第一场戏大概是我和雷恩在自动售货机旁。哦，天哪。这有点像是一种摸索的过程，因为我不确定，你知道的，该做多少即兴表演。你可不想一出现就表现得像
and me and him had a good, I felt like had good chemistry together too. So that was so easy. I can't believe that was your first scene. I'm pretty sure, yeah. You guys cracked up a lot and it's in the bloopers. Yeah. I actually was gonna play it. Ready? Are you ready? This is, you guys are so tickled. So, all right, here we go. Want a coffee? No, I'll probably just just finish the bag of chips. You want a soda? Again, you don't have to give me stuff.
那种人，对吧？对，对，对。你可不想一上来就气势汹汹。好像在说，各位，我有笑话要讲。我知道你们拿过一些艾美奖，但嘿，这是我的存货。你知道的，其实根本不需要太多的即兴表演，因为剧本本身就非常棒。但我记得，你知道的，那天还是有点紧张。但后来，你知道的，雷恩太搞笑了，我和他配合得很好，我觉得我们俩之间也很有化学反应。所以一切都很轻松。我简直不敢相信那是你的第一场戏。我挺确定的，是的。你们俩笑得前仰后合，这个被收录在花絮里了。是的。我其实本来想放出来的。准备好了吗？准备好了吗？这个是，你们俩太逗了。所以，好吧，我们开始吧。想要杯咖啡吗？不，我可能就吃完这袋薯片就行了。想要苏打水吗？再说一次，你不用给我拿东西。
I appreciate it though. I got some noodles in my car. Sorry, I'm cracking myself up. I got some noodles in my car. So we could just... Just go get in your car? I got some noodles in my car, we could just hang out and have some noodles. Zane, if you're more hungry, I got a big tub of noodles in my car.
不过我很感激。我车里有些面条。抱歉，我自己把自己逗笑了。我车里有些面条。所以我们可以……就去你车里？我车里有些面条，我们可以去那儿闲逛吃面条。赞恩，如果你更饿的话，我车里有一大桶面条。
Just get it out. This goes on. Super professional. This goes on for a few minutes. Literally every time you said, I got some noodles, you guys would start breaking. Well, we basically just met. Yeah, that is so fun though. You could already see the chemistry between the two characters.
去把它拿出来。这还没完。超级专业。这持续了好几分钟。真的，每次你说“我车里有些面条”，你们俩就开始笑场。好吧，我们基本上才刚认识。是的，不过那真的太有趣了。你已经能看出这两个角色之间的化学反应了。
Yeah, the hardest I've ever laughed and the one that's still like, if I catch it on TV, like I'm, I don't know if you guys know this, but the show airs a lot on cable. It does. So I see, yeah see like on Comedy Central and every channel. It seems to be on every channel. It's on a loop. But if I ever see the one where
是的，我笑得最厉害的一次，也是到现在如果我在电视上看到它，我就会——我不知道你们知不知道，这部剧在有线电视上重播很多次。确实如此。所以我看到，是的，比如在喜剧中心频道和每个频道上。它好像在每个频道都在播。它在循环播放。但如果我看到我们
we're trying to move Stanley's body. Down the stairs. Down the stairs. Stairmageddon. That to me, like I like, even like shooting, I could not hold it together. I was like, this is the funniest, like when this head launches into the wall. Into the wall. Oh my gosh. But that was the great thing about the show
试图搬运斯坦利的尸体的那一集。顺着楼梯。顺着楼梯。楼梯浩劫。对我来说，就像我——甚至在拍摄时，我都无法控制自己。我就觉得，这是最搞笑的，当他的头撞进墙里的时候。撞进墙里。哦，天哪。但这就是这部剧的伟大之处
and about mockumentary is the formula and the format of the show being so grounded with the mockumentary you can get away with really big broad stuff Because I was like at first I was like this is really silly like I don't know if this is gonna work at all But then you watch it and it totally works because like the you know the mockumentary thing grounds it But yeah that that was that's I still think about that laugh, just trying to shoot that and get through it, because nobody could keep it together. I love that you brought that up, because I feel like we were afraid to do that mix
也是伪纪录片形式的伟大之处，因为公式和节目形式与伪纪录片完美结合，扎实稳固，所以你可以驾驭非常夸张、大尺度的东西。因为我一开始觉得，这太荒唐了——我不知道这到底能不能行得通。但随后你看着它，发现它完全行得通，因为伪纪录片的形式把它稳住了。但是，是的，那就是——我仍然会想起那种笑声，试图拍摄它并坚持下来，因为没有人能忍住不笑。我很高兴你提起这个，因为我觉得我们一开始很害怕去尝试那种融合
of a broad concept, but keeping it in the mockumentary world. And it was Mindy's episode, The Injury, where Michael grills his foot, which is just such like a broad ridiculous idea. And after that episode worked, I felt like that was the writers were like, Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay. We see what we can do here. Meredith can have a bat attack her head. Yes. Or get hit by Michael's car. It really does though.
宏大概念，但又将其保持在伪纪录片世界中的做法。那是敏迪的一集，《受伤》，迈克尔把他的脚烤了，这真是一个如此夸张、荒谬的想法。在那一集成功之后，我觉得编剧们当时就在想，哦，好吧。是的。好吧。我们明白在这里可以做什么了。梅雷迪思可以让蝙蝠袭击她的头部。是的。或者被迈克尔的车撞。它确实是这样的。
It gives you a lot of freedom because I mean even think of the spinal tap. Yes. You know, like it's, yeah. That's the great, that's the thing that I love about my documentary. I've really got to do it twice because it doesn't come up a lot. Like I did it in Clark and Michael and then did it in the office. But yeah, I'd love to do more twice because it doesn't come up a lot. Like I did it in Clark and Michael and then did it in the office. But yeah, I'd love to do more mockumentary. Well, you're a writer director now.
它给了你很大的自由度，因为我的意思是，想想《摇滚万岁》。是的。你知道，就像是，是的。这就是我喜欢伪纪录片的地方。我真的有机会拍了两次，因为这种机会并不多。就像我在《克拉克和迈克尔》里拍过，然后又在《办公室》里拍了。但是，是的，我真的很想再拍两次，因为这种机会并不多。就像我在《克拉克和迈克尔》里拍过，然后又在《办公室》里拍了。但是，是的，我真的很想拍更多伪纪录片。好吧，你现在是编剧兼导演了。
That's true. Would you ever go that route? I actually have a script I'm working on right now that I would like to try to shoot this year that's a mockumentary, yeah. But I don't know if I'm gonna be in it. But yeah, definitely. Just because I miss, I miss, like it's such,
确实如此。你有没有想过走这条路？我其实现在手头有一个剧本正在写，我想试着今年把它拍出来，是一部伪纪录片，是的。但我不知道我是否会参演。但是，是的，绝对会。只是因为我想念，我想念，它简直是——
and it's such a fun way to shoot too. You know, you can move so fast. Like that was the other crazy thing about the office is how it felt like we shot a ton of pages a day. We did. Yeah, we did. Yeah, like compared to other stuff, like. So much, like yeah, like I'll.
这也是一种非常有趣的拍摄方式。你知道的，你可以进展得非常快。这就是《办公室》另一个疯狂的地方，我们感觉一天能拍大量的页数。我们确实拍了。是的，我们拍了。是的，比起其他作品，比如。太多了，就像，是的，我会。
Like 10 or 12 plus pages a day, which is a lot. I mean, I don't know if like people know like. twelve plus pages a day which is a lot I mean I don't know if like people know like that's a lot a lot of pages Yeah, a lot of pages and also, you know, we didn't move our lighting once we were in that main bullpen So we didn't have to wait for a lot of set up so we could move really quickly Which was great because as an actor you you kept the energy up Yeah, totally you wouldn't have that sort of slump as they would take forever to light. But I remember after being on the office and going through like 10, 12 pages a day, going to shoot a movie and I would look at the call sheet and I'd be like, we're doing seven eighths of a page today. Yeah. Like one or two pages. Yeah. Yeah. I'm
一天拍10到12页以上，这其实很多。我的意思是，我不知道人们是否知道，比如。一天拍12页以上，这其实很多。我的意思是，我不知道人们是否知道，比如这真的是很多页。是的，很多页。而且，你知道的，我们在那个主开放式办公区时，灯光一次都没移过。所以我们不需要等待太多的布景设置，因此我们可以进展得非常快。这太棒了，因为作为一名演员，你可以保持精力。是的，完全如此。你不会遇到那种因为灯光要弄上半天而产生的低潮。但我记得在参演《办公室》并经历了一天10到12页的拍摄量之后，去拍一部电影时，我会看着通告单说，我们今天只拍八分之七页。是的。就一两页。是的。是的。我
like, oh, okay. Yeah. It's a lot of sitting around. We're going to do this one page for 12 hours as opposed to 12 pages in 12 hours. It's great as an actor. I mean the Machiavellian thing too because you're shooting with you know two or three cameras usually at all times too so you can you know kind of like a Robert Altman thing like talk over each other and not have to worry about that and yeah I love that. Yeah. Well looking back on The Office is there a particular moment or episode that stands out to you as one of your favorites? I mean, Stare McGeddon.
就会想，哦，好吧。是的。有大量干坐着的时间。我们要花12小时拍这一页，而不是在12小时内拍12页。作为演员，这太棒了。我的意思是，伪纪录片这种形式也很棒，因为通常你随时都有两到三台摄像机在拍摄，所以你可以像罗伯特·奥 Altman 的作品那样，互相抢话，而不必担心那个问题，是的，我很喜欢这一点。回顾《办公室》时，有没有哪个特定的时刻或单集作为你的最爱脱颖而出？我是说，《楼梯浩劫》。
I already answered this one, but that episode, and the first one, the first one where you meet us, you know, was obviously a really special thing for me. Well, you know what? The one where Dwight takes me on the sales call when we go to the father-son... Is that Suit Warehouse? Yes. Yes. It's so good.
我已经回答过这个了，但是那一集，还有第一集，也就是你遇见我们的那一集，对当时的我和来说显然是非常特别的。好吧，你知道吗？有一集是德怀特带我去拜访客户，我们去那个父子……是西装仓库那一集吗？是的。是的。那一集太棒了。
That episode is so good. That might have been, that was a really fun one to shoot for me just because the stuff with Ryan was so fun. I mean the most surreal one or the one that like maybe sticks out the most was um the finale just because that was a little surreal. Like talk about the like transferring like senior year somewhere like and me and Jake Lacey have talked about this like it was it was kind of surreal because you know you guys had all been together so long and everybody's like crying and hugging. We kind of felt like two guys like standing around like
那一集真的太棒了。对我和来说，拍那一集真的非常有趣，因为和瑞恩的对手戏太好玩了。我的意思是，最超现实的一集，或者说可能最让人记忆深刻的一集是大结局，因为那感觉有点超现实。就像那种在高三时转学到某处的感觉——我和杰克·莱西聊过这个——这有点超现实，因为你们所有人在一起待了那么久，每个人都在哭泣和拥抱。我们感觉自己就像两个站在那里的人——
you feel kind of like you feel a little like like weird like like you're at like the funeral of someone like you just like. Should I go hug you? What do I do? Like an acquaintances funeral you know. know? So that was the most surreal thing probably. But yeah, funniest one is Sarah McGeddon for me. Like just could not keep it together. And then yeah, the first episode of that season where they introduce us. And then yeah, probably the Suit Warehouse. Well, you have one of my favorite talking heads.
你会感觉有点怪怪的，就像你出席某个人的葬礼一样——你只是觉得。我该去拥抱你吗？我该做什么？就像一个点头之交的葬礼，你知道的。所以这可能是最超现实的事情。但是，是的，最搞笑的对我来说是《楼梯浩劫》。简直笑得根本停不下来。然后，是的，那一季介绍我们登场的第一集。然后，是的，可能就是《西装仓库》了。好吧，你有一个我最喜欢的访谈。
It's when Clark is talking about his weekend with Jan. And it's one of my absolute favorites, and I want to play it. OK. Hey, guys. Clark, hey. Hey, look who's back. Dwight Jr.
就是克拉克谈论他和简的周末的那段。那绝对是我的最爱之一，我想把它放出来。好的。嘿，伙计们。克拉克，嘿。嘿，看看谁回来了。小德怀特。
Hey, so how was it? I mean, the sex with Jan. A gentleman doesn't discuss such matters, especially when the feelings of a lady are involved. Women reached their sexual peak at whatever age Jan was last week. I mean, it was like making love with a wild animal. But not like a cougar, like you might think.
嘿，所以感觉怎么样？我是说，和简发生关系。绅士是不会讨论这种事情的，尤其是涉及一位女士的感情时。女人在简上周那个年纪达到了她们的性高潮。我是说，这感觉就像和一只野生动物做爱。但不是像你想象的那种美洲狮。
It was like a swarm of bees. Bees that just find something wrong with every hotel room. That is so good! Your delivery is so great. Yeah, I did not write that line. I wish I did. That's excellent. That was a funny storyline in general. Because I think, if I remember right, I think that was sort of, the me and Jan thing was sort of written in because I had to go shoot a movie.
这感觉就像一群蜜蜂。那些对每个酒店房间都能挑出毛病的蜜蜂。太棒了！你的语气太棒了。是的，那句台词不是我写的。我希望是我写的。那太棒了。总的来说，那是一个有趣的故事情节。因为我觉得，如果我没记我和简的戏份之所以被写进剧本，是因为我要去拍电影。
And it was one of those deals where I was committed to that before I came on the show, so we had to carve it out type of deal. I think that was why the Jan thing was how they wrote me off. But yeah, what a great, funny way to do it for like three weeks. Do you have any offset behind the scenes memories when you look back at that time on the office,
而且那是那种在我加入剧组之前就已经承诺好的事情之一，所以我们必须把它腾出时间来处理。我想这就是为什么简的事情成了他们把我写走的方式。但是，是的，能用三周左右的时间做出这么棒、这么有趣的效果。当你回想起在《办公室》的那段时光时，你有什么片场幕后的记忆吗，
what do you think of? I mean, it was, I don't know, it was an interesting time. I like, I mean, I'm trying to think of stuff that would not be interesting to talk about. Cause I mean, for me, it's like, I think about, you know, like it felt like kind of a transitional moment in my life. Like I was moving, like I literally just moved from, so where they tape here, the podcast,
你会想起什么？我是说，那是一个，我不知道，那是一个有趣的时期。我喜欢，我是说，我一直在想那些聊起来不会觉得没意思的事情。因为我是说，对我来说，就像，我想到了，你知道的，就像那感觉像是生活中的一个过渡时刻。就像我要搬家，就像我刚刚从，也就是他们录制播客的地方，
I used to live across the street in this building and I had moved out of there and was like living in this, like this house I rented and yeah we should share with everyone when you walked in you're like oh my gosh from the windows where we record he can literally see the window of his apartment yeah I can see my old apartment across the street here yes I don't know so for me it was an interesting it was it was such a fun weird kind of year because it was like you know just being on the show felt like this fun gift
我以前住在街对面这栋楼里，我搬出了那里，然后住在像我租的这个房子里。是的，我们应该和大家分享一下，当你走进来的时候，你说，天哪，从我们录音的窗户里，他literally可以看到他公寓的窗户。是的，我可以看到街对面我的旧公寓。是的，我不知道，所以对我来说，这是一个有趣的一年，这是一个如此有趣、怪异的一年，因为就像，你知道的，能参演这部剧感觉就像是一个有趣的礼物，
that was just put in my lap that I got to do for a year. So it was just kind of pure joy, because I mean, you know, like I said earlier, a lot of shows are not that fun to shoot. I mean, especially now that everything is kind of just like, a lot of TV shows now are like movies that never end, like single camera stuff. It's like, you know, you can go shoot a movie
直接落在了我的腿上，让我能演一年。所以这只是一种纯粹的快乐，因为我是说，你知道的，就像我刚才说的，很多节目拍起来并没有那么有趣。我是说，尤其是现在一切都变得像，现在的很多电视剧都像是永无止境的电影，就像单镜头拍摄的东西。就像，你知道的，你可以去拍一部电影
for like two or three months and do like the crazy hours because it's only for like, you know, a couple of months. But doing that like nine months a year, like really like wears on you after a while. Yeah. So yeah, it was such a fun year. You know, the main thing that kind of took me back because I'd never done,
拍两三个月，然后熬那些疯狂的夜班，因为那只持续几个月，你知道的。但一年有九个月都这么做，一段时间后真的会让你筋疲力尽。所以，是的，那是多么有趣的一年。你知道，最让我感到意外的是，因为我从来没有做过，
I had never done a show that did that many episodes a year. And so it was really interesting for me just to watch the kind of ebbs and flows of like, everybody's got so much energy, you know, at first. And then by like, I remember there's like a hiatus, like midway through, and it's like, you need it because everyone's about to die, you know, from exhaustion. And then it was like the scripts after that, like in everybody's energy, like, OK, everybody's got way more energy again, you know, from like exhaustion. And then it was like the scripts after that, like in everybody's energy, like, okay, everybody's got way more energy again, you know, to kind of like carry you through. It was interesting for me just to watch the sort of endurance and the kind of rhythm of the thing and how you had to kind of pace yourself a little bit.
我从来没有拍过一年有那么多集的电视剧。所以对我来说，观察大家的能量起伏非常有趣，你知道，一开始大家都精力充沛。然后到了中间，我记得有个间歇期，就像你需要它一样，因为每个人都快累死了，你知道的。然后接下来的剧本，就像每个人的能量一样，就像，好吧，每个人又都有了更多的能量，你知道的，来支撑你度过难关。对我来说，观察这种耐力和节奏感，以及你如何不得不稍微调整一下自己的节奏，非常有趣。
And also just how fast stuff would come out. Like we would shoot an episode and it'd be on TV, like, was it like two or three weeks later? Like really fast. Yeah, the turnaround was really quick. Yeah, the turnaround blew my mind. Yeah. Because I'd also never built anything that turned around that fast before.
还有就是东西出炉的速度有多快。就像我们拍完一集，它就能在电视上播出，是两三周后吗？真的非常快。是的，周转时间非常快。是的，周转速度让我大吃一惊。是的，因为我以前也从未制作过周转这么快的东西。
Well, we'd get a script and we'd read it midweek and then we'd shoot it the next week. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah, I think for me just the process of it was really interesting to watch as far as the offsets. I guess that's still on set, but that was cool to me. I mean, one thing that I, you know, liked about the show so much, it was so excited about when I initially got the offer was the idea of, you know,
好吧，我们拿到剧本，周中读完，然后下周就拍。是的。所以，是的，我觉得对我来说，单单是这个制作过程就非常有趣，无论是片场外的事情。我想那仍然算是在片场，但这对我来说很酷。我是说，我（你知道的）非常喜欢这部剧的一点，当我最初接到邀约时感到非常兴奋的是那种，你知道的，
eventually being like like B.J. or Mindy and being like a writer producer kind of role in the show, too. And it went on longer. I'm so curious because, you know, over in the little accounting nook, we had our different bits that we would do with one another. Did you and Jake back in the annex, like sitting across from each other, did you have like bits that you did? Um, did you have the Zen garden? No. Remember how there was that that little sand Zen garden that left? Oh, I know. I don't recall it was Zen Garden.
最终能像B.J.或明迪那样，在剧中扮演编剧兼制片人之类的角色。而且这部剧还拍了更长时间。我太好奇了，因为，你知道的，在那个小会计角落里，我们互相之间有很多不同的搞笑桥段。你和杰克在后屋里，面对面坐着，你们有什么常玩的搞笑桥段吗？呃，你们有禅意花园吗？没有。还记得以前那儿有个小沙盘禅意花园吗？哦，我知道。我不记得有什么禅意花园了。
Yeah, it used to be back in the annex. I don't think we did, because you know, weirdly, we didn't film, it feels like we didn't film a whole lot of stuff back there. Like I remember filming way more stuff with you than I do back there. But I mean, Paul would always crack me up. Yeah. Paul makes me laugh really hard. I ended up doing a, Paul directed a movie that I was in
是的，以前在后屋。我觉得我们没有，因为很奇怪，我们好像没在那里拍过很多东西。就像我记得跟你一起拍的东西比在后面拍的多得多。不过我是说，保罗总是能把我逗乐。是的。保罗真的把我逗得哈哈大笑。我后来拍了一部，保罗导演了一部电影，我在里面演了角色，
a few years after called Song and That Come Back. Oh right. Yeah. And then we did during, Paul called me during like the lockdown part of COVID and I ended up doing this, it was like an audible middle space. Yeah. Yeah, it's great. It's so funny. Yeah. But it was so, that was then that most surreal part of like COVID in LA where, so they delivered like a sound booth to my house.
几年后叫《之歌》。哦，对的。是的。然后我们在新冠疫情封锁期间，保罗给我打了电话，我最后做了一个类似有声书中间地带的东西。是的。是的，太棒了。太搞笑了。是的。但那是，那是洛杉矶新冠疫情期间最超现实的部分，因为他们把一个隔音亭送到了我家。
And like I built this like, they sent like a kit. They didn't even build, this is like what nobody would even like, like. Come in your house. No, no, it was like, we're gonna drop this giant refrigerator size thing outside like in your driveway. And so I builtsized thing outside, like, in your driveway. And so I built this thing of, like, PVC pipe in my garage.
就像我建了一个像这样的，他们寄来了一个套件。他们甚至没帮我建，这是没人会想到的那种。送到你家里。不，不，就像是，我们要把这个巨大的冰箱大小的东西扔在外面，比如你的车道上。所以我用PVC管在我的车库里搭建了这个东西。
You built it? Well, I mean, it's like... It's like Legos? Yeah, yeah. It's not that elaborate. I don't want to oversell, like, yeah. It had, like, instructions and, you know, it's literally just like PVC pipe. But still, you basically had to do an Ikea build.
你建的？好吧，我是说，就像……就像乐高积木？对，对。没那么复杂。我不想过分夸大，就像，是的。它有说明书，你知道的，真的就是像PVC管一样。但即便如此，你基本上得完成一次宜家组装。
Yeah, yeah. Exactly. You had to do an Ikea build of this thing and build a little like soundproof booth with the blanket over it and the whole thing and the mic and the stand and yeah. Sounds crazy. I was going to ask you if you took anything from the set when we wrapped because Jenna and I took a bunch of stuff. I took a bunch of shirts and a couple ties. You did? For your real life? Like that you would wear in your real life?
对，对。完全正确。你必须像组装宜家家具一样组装这个东西，用毯子盖在上面建一个隔音小亭子，还有麦克风和支架，诸如此类。听起来太疯狂了。我正想问你，当我们杀青时，你有没有从片场拿走什么东西，因为珍娜和我拿了一堆东西。我拿了一堆衬衫和几条领带。你拿了？为了你的现实生活？就像你会在现实生活中戴的那种？
Well, I could, but I really don't. It was more keepsakes. It was, yeah. That was my question. Because I didn't really have any other props to speak of. You know what I mean? Because I never had a desk I'd been at for a long time or anything.
嗯，我可以，但我真的没穿。这更多是留作纪念。是的，那是我的问题。因为我真的没有什么别的道具可言。你知道我的意思吗？因为我从来没有一张我坐了很久的办公桌什么的。
I took this very specific tie. Because I feel like I only had like two or three ties that rotated a lot, which was one thing that I liked about the show is it was kind of a real thing is you'd see clothes repeat. Yeah. Because you know, normally on TV shows, you'll like never see the same outfit.
我拿了这根非常特别的领带。因为我觉得我只有两三根经常轮流戴的领带，这也是我喜欢这部剧的一点，它挺现实的，你会看到衣服重复出现。是的。因为你知道，通常在电视剧里，你几乎永远不会看到同样的衣服。
Same outfit ever again. But I had like two or three ties, so I have one or two of those, and one that I see those on TV all the time, and it cracks me up. Oh, I love that. You mentioned how you didn't really have a desk, necessarily, so much that you sat out a lot.
再也不会看到同一套衣服了。但我有两三条领带，所以我留了一两条，有一条我总能在电视上看到它们，这让我忍俊不禁。哦，我太喜欢了。你提到你其实没有一张固定的办公桌，更多的时候是你坐在外面。
And that reminded me of one of my favorite episodes, which is when you won't leave Jim's desk when he comes back. Yes. And your showdown with him is so good. It's really good. I love it. You're like, oh, because I'm here to sell paper.
这让我想起了我最喜欢的剧集之一，也就是当吉姆回来时，你赖着不肯离开他的办公桌。是的。你和他的对峙太棒了。真的太棒了。我太喜欢了。你说，哦，因为我是来卖纸的。
Yeah. I would love to sit by my wife. All business. Yeah. Do you still get recognized from your time on the show? Oh my God. To a degree that like blows my mind. Only because I was only on the show for the one season.
是的。我很愿意坐在我妻子旁边。全心扑在工作上。是的。你现在走在街上还会因为这部剧而被认出来吗？哦，天哪。程度之高让我感到震惊。仅仅因为我只在这部剧里演了一季。
But no, the office is like, I mean, it's like, I don't know, I've never been a part of anything like this big, you know, like now with like, it feels like it's so much bigger now than when the show was on too. Oh yeah. Like with like the conventions. I mean, there's people, I know people that are,
但是，不，《办公室》就像是，我是说，它就像是，我不知道，我从来没有参与过这么大的项目，你知道的，就像现在这样，感觉现在的热度比当年播出时还要大得多。哦，是的。就像那些粉丝见面会。我是说，有很多人，我认识的人，
people come up to you and tell me this, that they just like watch the show on loop. I think it is bigger in a sense because there's all the people who watched it when it was originally on and now there are these additional generations who have found it and love it, but that first generation is also still watching it. So it's just this like cumulative fan base and it's... No, I would say like at least once a day, somebody in real life will say like, oh my
人们会走到我面前告诉我这个，他们一直在单曲循环看这部剧。从某种意义上说，它确实更火了，因为不仅有当年首播时的老观众，现在还有这些发现了它并爱上它的新一代观众，而第一代观众也依然在看。所以这就像是一个不断累积的粉丝群体，而且……不，我会说，至少一天一次，现实生活中会有人说，哦，天哪，
God, were you Clark from the office? Which is another reason to use your real name when you're on a TV show. Oh, it's good times, isn't it? I have this story that Jenna knows that I had lunch with Rain. We were leaving this little cafe and someone drove by and they yelled, Angela! And I was like, what? Oh, wait, sorry Rain, I might know them. And then they yelled, Dwight!
你难道不是《办公室》里的克拉克吗？这也是为什么你在拍电视剧时应该用真名。哦，那真是美好的时光，不是吗？我有个故事珍娜知道，我和雷恩一起吃午饭。我们离开这个小咖啡馆时，有人开车路过，他们大喊，安吉拉！我当时就想，什么？哦，等等，抱歉雷恩，我可能认识他们。然后他们大喊，德怀特！
He goes, oh no, they yell your name. I was like, what? Oh wait, sorry, Rain, I might know them. And then they yelled, Dwight! He goes, oh no, they yell your name! I was like, they do, and every time I turn around and I think I might know someone. My favorite story that's similar to that is, after I had, this was like 2007 or something, I think the only thing I'd done was Clark and Michael and it was just on the internet. And I remember being at, we were at San Diego Comic-Con, like promoting some movie that hadn't come out yet, and somebody drove by in a car and yelled, internet! At me, which was one of my all-time favorite. But the weirdest thing is I turned around, I went like, I knew, I knew it was directed at me. Yeah.
他说，哦不，他们喊的是你的名字。我当时想，什么？哦，等等，抱歉，雷恩，我可能认识他们。然后他们大喊，德怀特！他说，哦不，他们喊的是你的名字！我说，他们确实喊了，每次我一转身，我还以为我可能认识某个人呢。我最喜欢的一个类似的故事是，在我经历过之后，这大概是2007年左右吧，我想我唯一做过的就是克拉克和迈克尔，而且它只在互联网上播过。我记得当时在，我们在圣迭戈动漫展上，宣传某部还没上映的电影，有人开车路过，大喊，互联网！冲着我喊，这是我所有经历中最喜欢的一个。但最奇怪的是我转过身去，我说，我知道，我知道那是冲着我喊的。是的。
That's pretty great. But no, like, no, the office thing is really like, like I said, it continues to blow my mind. But I mean, you're also, you know, it's so cool now with kind of, and I sort of knew this at the time, but even more now, like, you got to be part of one of the all-time shows.
这太棒了。不过，办公室的事真的，就像我说的，依然让我感到震撼。但我的意思是，你也是，你知道的，现在这样真的很酷，我当时其实就有点这种感觉，但现在更是觉得，你能够成为有史以来最伟大的剧集之一的一员。
I mean, this was like My Generation's Seinfeld, or Cheers, or you know. Yeah, just a classic show that everyone you knew watched at some point. Yeah, I remember one time Greg Daniels said something to me, and I'm going to paraphrase it and butcher it, but he said something along the lines of, in life you don't get that many
我的意思是，这就像是我们这代人的《宋飞传》，或者《欢乐酒店》，你知道的。是的，就是那种每个人认识的人在某个时候都看过的经典剧集。是的，我记得有一次格雷格·丹尼尔斯对我说过一句话，我试着用自己的话复述一下，可能说得不太好，但他的意思大致是，在生活中，你不会有那么多
like really big bites at the apple. And like, you know, that was one of them for sure. Like that show. Yeah, yeah. I mean, Jenna and I definitely felt that when we started the podcast. We were like, well we don't want to get anything wrong because the show means so much to everyone.
真正能大展身手的大好机会。就像，你知道的，那绝对是其中之一。就像那部剧一样。对，对。我的意思是，我和珍娜在开始做播客时确实有这种感觉。我们当时想，嗯，我们可不想弄出什么差错，因为这部剧对每个人都意义重大。
And they will correct you. They will let you know, but they're always, they're very kind, I have to say. They are. They will say, ladies, that cold open actually was a tag and you got it wrong. Like, oh, sorry. Yeah.
而且他们会纠正你。他们会让你知道，不过他们总是，我得说，他们非常随和。确实是的。他们会说，女士们，那个冷场开场其实是个尾声，你们弄错了。哦，对不起。是的。
I think it's because, you know, it's sort of that thing that like, I mean, the only thing I compare it to is like, you know, like Stern Show or something that you listen to like every day for hours on end. Like it almost, it feels like they're like Stern show or something that you listen to like every day for hours on end like it almost it feels like they're like your friends or family members and I mean I think people have like watched the show and lived with the show for so long now especially people that have watched it
我想这是因为，你知道的，这有点像那种感觉，我的意思是，我能把它作类比的唯一东西就是，你知道的，比如斯特恩秀或者那种你每天听好几个小时的东西。这几乎，感觉就像是，就像斯特恩秀或者那种你每天听好几个小时的东西，这几乎，感觉就像他们是你的朋友或家庭成员，我的意思是，我觉得人们看这部剧并陪伴这部剧生活了这么久，特别是那些一直看的人
like you know over like straight through over and over you know you feel like you know the people yeah and it feels like it feels like hanging out with friends I think well we did an entire re-watch of every single episode of the show. And you are a complete delight. You're a breath of fresh air when you come on in season nine. So funny.
你知道的，一遍又一遍地连着看，你会觉得你认识这些人，是的，感觉就像，感觉就像和朋友一起闲逛，我觉得，我们在节目中对每一集进行了完整的重看。而你真的是个十足的开心果。你在第九季加入时，就像是一股清风。太有趣了。
I really enjoyed season nine. You and Jake were a big reason why. I had a blast. I thought, as just a viewer and a fan, I thought season nine was really strong in general. Agree. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did too. Plus, I thought, as just a viewer and a fan, I thought season nine was really strong in general. Agreed. Yeah.
我真的很喜欢第九季。你和杰克是其中很大的原因。我玩得很开心。作为一个观众和粉丝，我认为第九季总体上非常强势。同意。是的。是的。我也这么觉得。而且，作为一个观众和粉丝，我认为第九季总体上非常强势。同意。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. I did too. Well, Clark, you have transitioned now into writing and directing and acting. You had your film Arkansas, which was based on a novel. It is an amazing mix of crime and dark humor and drama. Angela was very impressed by your cast. I really was.
对。对。我也这么觉得。嗯，克拉克，你现在转型成了编剧、导演和演员。你拍了电影《阿肯色州》，它是根据小说改编的。这是一部完美的犯罪、黑色幽默和剧情的结合体。安吉拉对你的演员阵容印象深刻。我真的很深刻。
I was looking at it on IMTV and I was like, holy moly. Liam Hemsworth, Michael Kenneth Williams, Vivica A. Fox, Eden Brolin, Chandler Duke, your brother, John Malkovich, and Vince Vaughn. Wow. What was it like working with that cast? It was great. I mean, it was sort of the same thing as The Office. It just makes your life as a director really easy.
我在IMDb上看到它时，我心想，我的天哪。利亚姆·海姆斯沃斯、迈克尔·肯尼斯·威廉姆斯、维维卡·A·福克斯、伊登·布罗林、钱德勒·杜克、你的弟弟、约翰·马尔科维奇和文斯·沃恩。哇。和这样的演员阵容合作是什么感觉？太棒了。我的意思是，这和《办公室》差不多。这让你的导演生活变得非常轻松。
Somebody said, oh, what was it like directing John Malkovich? I'm like, a director really easy. Like somebody said like, oh what was it like directing like John Malkovich? I'm like, it's really easy. He's John. John Malkovich. Yeah. He gets it. Yeah, he knows all of our lines. I'd look over and he'd be like putting a mat
有人说，哦，导演约翰·马尔科维奇是什么感觉？我说，导演生活非常轻松。就像有人说，哦，导演约翰·马尔科维奇是什么感觉？我说，这真的很轻松。他是约翰。约翰·马尔科维奇。是的。他懂的。是的，他知道我们所有的台词。我抬头看过去，他竟然在铺垫
over a loose cable and like, I mean. Helping the crew out. No, literally. He's just a delight. Yeah, I love John Malkovich. I still email with him every now and then Yeah, I mean it makes it just makes your life really easy like more than anything and again I mean, I think a lot of it just comes down to chemistry like I felt like me and Liam
一条松动的电缆，我的意思是。在帮剧组的忙。不，真的。他简直是个宝藏。是的，我爱约翰·马尔科维奇。我到现在还偶尔跟他发邮件。是的，我的意思是这真的让你的生活变得很简单，最重要的是，而且再说一次，我觉得很大程度上还是归结于化学反应，比如我觉得我和利亚姆
Had a good like we had a good back and forth with each other And we were friends and have stayed friends Yeah, I mean that was that was what I you know I really I came out here to go to school to be a writer-director. Like that was really what I wanted to do more so than the acting. And then like, you know, kind of by virtue of being in Clark and Michael, kind of got the acting career and did that for a nice long time and had a blast. But I always, you know, I was always like making shorts and I was always writing. And like, I mean, I had the option to the book, Arkansas, for probably almost like a decade.
合作得很默契，我们俩有很多很好的互动，而且我们成了朋友，并且一直保持着友谊。是的，我的意思是，这就是我，你知道的，我来这里上学是为了成为一名编剧兼导演。那才是我真正想做的，比演戏更想做。然后，你知道的，因为出演了克拉克和迈克尔这个角色，稀里糊涂地开启了演艺生涯，演了很长一段时间，玩得很开心。但我一直，你知道的，我一直在拍短片，我一直在写作。而且，我的意思是，我拥有《阿肯色州》这本书的改编权大概有快十年了。
And then finally I was like, all right, you get to now or never. So it didn't feel, it doesn't feel like an abrupt change to me. Right, because it's always been part of you. Well, yeah, and I was always wanting to do it and kind of trying to do it. But it was hard because, I mean, thank God,
然后我终于想，好吧，现在不做更待何时。所以这感觉不，对我来说并不觉得是一个突兀的转变。对，因为这一直都是你的一部分。嗯，是的，我一直都想这么做，也一直在努力这么做。但很难，因为，感谢上帝，
I got to work a lot as an actor. And that takes a lot of time up. But you know, like, it was hard because I, I mean, thank God, you know, I got to work a lot as an actor. And that takes a lot of time up, that's a full-time job. Yeah. So it was sort of a matter of like, after the last show was on, which Jake Lacey was also on, called I'm Dying Up Here on Showtime.
我作为演员有很多工作机会。那占用了大量的时间。但你知道的，这很难，因为，我的意思是，感谢上帝，你知道的，我作为演员有很多工作机会。那占用了大量的时间，那是一份全职工作。是的。所以这有点像，上一部剧播完之后，杰克·莱西也参演了，那是Showtime电视台的一部剧，叫《活着真难》。
We also did this other TV show together. That's wild. Yeah. And now he's in your next movie. He is, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, me and Jake are on these parallel paths
我们还一起合作了另一部电视剧。太疯狂了。是的。现在他还在你的下一部电影里。是的，没错。对。对。不，我和杰克走在平行的人生道路上。
with each other. Your third project. Yeah. But it was kind of like after that show, I'm Dying Up Here ended, I finally got to make Arkansas, which I'd been trying to make for a few years at that point. And to the degree that it had different producers
彼此交织。你的第三个项目。是的。但差不多就是在那部剧《活着真难》结束之后，我终于得以拍摄《阿肯色州》，在那之前我已经尝试了好几年。鉴于它有不同的制片人
and a completely different cast, it went multiple points. And then somehow it just like, and so much of it is just scheduling and timing. Malkovich had a week in October or whatever. So it's like, all right. We gotta make it happen. It's like, all right, we're shooting in October. Yeah.
和一个完全不同的演员阵容，它经历了几个不同的阶段。然后不知怎么的，很多事情都取决于档期和时机。马尔科维奇在十月份或者别的什么时间有一个星期的空档。所以就像是，好吧。我们得把这事定下来。就像是，好吧，我们在十月开机。是的。
But it was, yeah after after that that show wrapped up I really just you know threw myself into that and worked on that for you know like a couple of years like making a movie takes a really long time. It does. Yeah. It really does. I remember when my husband and I, we made this indie, the giant mechanical man, like from our first meeting until it came out, we fell in love while we were making this movie, by the way. And so from that first time we met, where I was like, here's the pitch meeting where you're pitching me the movie
但确实，在那部剧杀青之后，我真的就，你知道的，全身心投入到那个项目中，为之努力了，你知道的，大概好几年。拍一部电影真的需要很长时间。确实。是的。真的需要。我记得我和我丈夫，我们拍了那部独立电影《巨型机械人》，从我们第一次开会到它上映，顺便说一句，我们在拍这部电影的时候坠入爱河了。所以从我们第一次见面，当时我说，这就是你向我推销电影的提案会议
and I say yes, and then we go off, we're gonna try to get it made. We fell in love, we got married, I got pregnant and I had a baby. All of that happened before the movie came out. It was like five years. Yeah, no. And that's sadly, I mean, especially with independent movies, like that's kind of the norm. So yeah, like I said, I've been trying to make that movie for years and then spent two plus years or whatever making it. And then it finally came out right as COVID started.
我答应了，然后我们出发，我们要把它拍出来。我们坠入爱河，我们结婚了，我怀孕了，我还生了个孩子。所有这一切都在电影上映前发生了。花了大约五年时间。是的，没错。不幸的是，我的意思是，特别是对独立电影来说，这几乎成了常态。所以，是的，就像我说的，我为了拍那部电影努力了好多年，然后花了两年多的时间把它拍完。结果它刚好在新冠疫情爆发的时候上映了。
Like the movie came out May of 2020. So that was like right when all the like, you know, lockdowns and everything started. So did you get to have the big premiere? No. Or anything? No. Was it in theaters? No.
电影是在2020年5月上映的。所以那正好是所有那些，你知道的，封城和一切开始的时候。所以你们办了盛大的首映礼吗？没有。还是别的什么？没有。在电影院上映了吗？没有。
No. We were going to be. Of course. We were going to be. We almost made it. Yeah. It would have been like the last independent film in theaters. Oh, man. No. As an artist, I know just because of how long it
没有。我们本打算去的。当然。我们本打算去的。差一点就成了。是的。它本来会是电影院里最后一部独立电影。哦，天哪。不，作为一名艺术家，我知道仅仅因为
takes to push the boulder up the mountain and then. Not to get to celebrate it in that big way. Yeah, it felt really anticlimactic. I mean, I didn't want to feel too, you know, like sorry for myself just because there was such like real life, you know, horror going on with everybody. For sure. But no, it's tough. It's kind of a tough pill to swallow because like you said, you spend like years and years
推着巨石上山花了那么长时间，然后。却没能以那种盛大的方式去庆祝它。是的，感觉真的很反高潮。我的意思是，我不想显得太，你知道的，自怨自艾，因为每个人都在经历真正的现实生活中的，你知道的，恐怖。确实如此。但说实话，这很难。这算是一个很难咽下的苦果，因为就像你说的，你花了整整好几年
on it. But it ended up doing great on VOD. It was one of the first like, you know, like I feel like movies that got moved to VOD. So I think it felt like we were like, it was like us and like Sonic the Hedgehog like the only movies even available to watch type of thing. So we ended up doing really well. And yeah, now I'm in post right now on my second film
在上面。但它最终在点播平台上表现得很好。它是那种，你知道的，我感觉是最早转到点播平台的电影之一。所以我感觉我们就像是，就像我们和《刺猬索尼克》是仅有的两部可看的电影一样。所以我们最终表现得非常棒。是的，现在我正在为我的第二部电影做后期制作
that me and my brother Chandler wrote, and he's in, he acts in this one too, and he was in Arkansas as well, but I'm not in this one. I just directed this one, but. What's it like to have a project like that with your brother? How do you guys work together? Yeah, do you have a ritual when you're writing?
我和我弟弟钱德勒一起写的，他也在这部里演了角色，他在《阿肯色州》里也演过，但我没演这部。我只导演了这一部。和你的弟弟一起做一个项目是什么感觉？你们平时怎么合作？是的，你们写作时有什么仪式感吗？
A little bit. So it was sort of, you know, that was probably like one positive thing that came out of, you know, the kind of long quarantine of everybody is I had rented an office space literally like a month before all that started, like, and everybody got, you know, locked in their houses. I had rented an office space, literally like a month before all that started, like everybody got locked in their houses. I had rented these two offices. So me and my brother and his writing partner from college,
有一点吧。所以这有点像，你知道的，那可能是从，你知道的，大家经历漫长隔离中产生的一个积极成果吧，我在这一切开始前大概一个月租了一间办公室，就在大家都被，你知道的，关在家里之前。我租了一间办公室，就在这一切开始前大概一个月，就在大家都被关在家里之前。我租了两间办公室。所以我和我弟弟以及他在大学时的写作搭档
Billington, just started going there every day. And so, just to kind of keep from going crazy, and just have somewhere to go, and it still felt very safe. It's just the three of us, and we don't see anybody else. Like a second quarantine. A little bit, yeah, but it was at least
比灵顿，我们刚开始每天去那里。所以，为了不让自己发疯，也为了能有个地方可去，而且那里感觉依然很安全。只有我们三个人，我们看不到任何人。就像第二次隔离一样。
like a second location. So thank God, like, you know, we had that and we had each other to kind of like talk to, but we started going over there and we just started writing every day and we wrote, you know, over a couple of years, like, I don't know, like four or five or six movie scripts. So we got- Wow.
有点像吧，但至少那是第二个地方。所以谢天谢地，你知道的，我们有彼此可以倾诉，我们开始去那里，每天开始写作，你知道的，在几年里我们写了，我不知道，大约四、五、六个电影剧本。所以我们——哇。
Yeah, so we have some material now and this is the first one. And then after all the lockdowns kind of died down, like this movie Stranglehold was going to get made, and then it was like gearing up, and then the strikes happened. So then we had to take another 18 months off or whatever. But anyway, we finally shot the thing, and now I'm starting, well not starting, we're on to the point now, we're on to the like the point now we're about to start the music you're in post-production we're in
是的，所以我们现在有一些素材，这是第一部。在各种封锁渐渐平息之后，这部名为《死死攥住》的电影本来要开拍了，当时正在筹备中，然后罢工就发生了。所以我们不得不又休假了18个月左右。不过无论如何，我们终于把这片子拍完了，现在我开始，也不是开始，我们已经到了那个阶段，我们已经到了准备开始做音乐的阶段，你正在进行后期制作，我们在
post-production like most of the editing is done but now we got to do all the the color and sound and the music and all that all that kind of stuff but the movie will probably come out it's a Christmas movie I was gonna say can you tell us a little bit about it yeah I love a Christmas movie it's she loves a Christmas I'm very excited already. Can I come to the premiere? Yeah, there's a premiere. Yes, of course. I just confided myself.
后期制作中，大部分剪辑已经完成了，但现在我们得做调色、音效、音乐以及所有诸如此类的事情。不过这部电影可能会上映，这是一部圣诞电影。我正想说，你能跟我们多聊聊吗？太好了，我喜欢圣诞电影。她喜欢圣诞电影，我已经非常兴奋了。我能去首映礼吗？对，会有首映礼。当然可以。我刚才自己偷偷决定了。
I have a red plaid dress I can wear. Okay, go on. It's set at Christmas and it's about a stripper and her alcoholic veteran husband who decide to rob the strip club she works at at Christmas. Okay. So.
我有一条红色的格子裙可以穿。好吧，你继续。故事设定在圣诞节，讲的是一个脱衣舞娘和她酗酒的老兵丈夫，决定在圣诞节去抢劫她工作的脱衣舞俱乐部。好吧。所以。
Merry Christmas! Yeah. Yeah. Who else in it? Ashley Benson and Jake Lacey. Oh, nice. Are they the couple? They're the couple.
圣诞快乐！是的。是的。还有谁参演？阿什莉·本森和杰克·莱西。哦，不错。他们演那对夫妻？他们演那对夫妻。
Okay. Justin Long. Okay. Ron Perlman is the owner of the club and Justin plays his son, which is very funny. David Arquette is in the film, Brian Possein's in the film. Yeah, we got another great cast. Yeah, another great cast. So cool.
好吧。贾斯汀·朗。好吧。朗·普尔曼饰演俱乐部的老板，贾斯汀饰演他的儿子，这非常搞笑。大卫·阿尔凯特参演了这部电影，布莱恩·波森也参演了。是的，我们又得到了一套超棒的演员阵容。是的，又一套超棒的阵容。太酷了。
Yeah, but I am not in it. Did you like not being in it? Did you like, did you prefer? I wanted to try it. You wanted to try it. I wanted to try it. Yeah, is this your first film you've directed that you've not been in?
对，但我没有参演。你喜欢不参演吗？你喜欢，还是更喜欢不参演？我想尝试一下。你想要尝试。我想尝试。是的，这是你执导的第一部没有亲自出演的电影吗？
Well, I've only made the two, so yes. Well, and I guess. Well, but yeah, but even like Clark and Michael and all those. Yeah I was on all those too. Yeah you're right. So this is your first time strictly being behind the camera? It was. It was because now that I think about it even like the shorts and stuff I'd made over the years I was always with those too. So yeah it was. How'd you like it? It was a mix. I mean we had so few days like we shot the whole whole movie in like 17 or 18 days or so. So I mean, I couldn't have physically done it.
嗯，我总共只拍了两部，所以是的。嗯，我想也是。嗯，不过是的，甚至包括《克拉克和迈克尔》以及所有那些。对，那些我也都参演了。对，你说的对。所以这是你第一次纯粹退居幕后？是的。是的，因为现在回想起来，甚至包括我这些年拍过的短片之类的，我总是也参演那些。所以是的，确实是。你觉得怎么样？挺复杂的。我的意思是，我们的拍摄时间太短了，我们大概只用17、18天左右就把整部电影拍完了。所以我的意思是，我身体上根本不可能做到。
Right. Like I would have collapsed, you know. It was sort of more out of necessity. Because I did like the part that Justin played I wrote for myself, you know, initially, but it just became like a logistical thing. But I also wanted to try it and just see, you know, what the difference was and if I did feel like it improved anything. Honestly, I kind of miss being in it though.
对。我可能会累垮的，你知道的。这在某种程度上更多是出于无奈。因为我本来挺喜欢贾斯汀演那个角色的，我最初是为自己写的，你知道的，但它最终变成了一个后勤调度的问题。但我也想尝试一下，看看有什么不同，以及我是不是会觉得有什么改进。老实说，我其实有点怀念参与演出的感觉。
I don't know. I think I might go, I don't know. I'm on the fence. It depends on what day you ask me. Yeah. I know. I always think about that too. I had written this short film one time and I was going to direct it and then I decided
我不知道。我想我可能会去，我不知道。我还在犹豫。这取决于你问我的时候是星期几。是的。我懂。我总是也会想到这一点。我有一次写了一部短片，我本来打算自己导演的，然后我决定
no, I need someone else. I need that third eye. So my friend stepped in to direct it But then I kind of micromanaged him and I was also in it. So I don't think I could not be in it I think I want to do bits I want to be in there, you know The thing for me that I found on on Arkansas because I was you know, I was in like 80% of that movie But I kind of found a lot of times it was sort of just one less person to deal with
不，我需要别人。我需要第三只眼。所以我的朋友介入来导演，但我有点微操他，而且我也在里面演。所以我觉得我没法不演。我觉得我想演一些小片段，我想参与其中，你知道的。对我来说，在拍《阿肯色》时我发现的事情是，因为我（你知道的）出演了那部电影里大约80%的内容，但我发现很多时候，这实际上只是少了一个需要应付的人。
Like oh, it's kind of found a lot of times it was sort of just one less person to deal with like oh It's kind of like one person you don't have to direct and I mean like when you have really good actors That's sort of not much of an issue anyway But I was like, you know I knew what I wanted the character to kind of be and do and right I knew what I want the line-reading to be You know type of thing one less note to give yeah kind of so I didn't really mind it But I also didn't really know any different because I'd only ever acted in the stuff that I directed But so I don't know going forward. I would you know, I miss doing comedy Mm-hmm, like acting wise I miss doing comedy and they just don't make like theatrical like they don't they don't exist
就像，哦，很多时候这实际上只是少了一个需要应付的人。就像，哦，这就像少了一个你不需要去导演的人，我的意思是，当你拥有非常优秀的演员时，这其实已经算不上什么大问题了。但我当时就想，你知道的，我知道我希望这个角色大概是什么样、做什么，而且对，我知道我想要什么样的台词语气，你知道的那种。少给一个指令，对吧，差不多就是这样。所以我其实并不介意。但我也确实不知道有什么不同，因为我以前只在我导演的作品里演过戏。所以，我不知道以后会怎样，我（你知道的）怀念演喜剧的感觉。嗯，就演技而言，我怀念演喜剧的感觉，而现在他们根本不拍那种院线电影，它们不复存在了。
Yeah, weird, right? It's very weird. Like I don't understand it because I know people I mean, I guess it just moved the TV But I miss um, I guess it just moved the TV, but I miss... I miss a good funny movie where you're laughing so hard. I know, and I was very blessed. I got to spend a bunch of years acting in those, and it was so fun. So I miss that. Yeah, that used to kind of be... There was always a couple. There were these big summer summer blockbuster comedy and there
是的，很奇怪对吧？非常奇怪。就像我无法理解，因为我认识人，我的意思是，我猜它只是转向了电视，但我想……我猜它只是转向了电视，但我怀念……我怀念一部能让你笑得前俯后仰的优秀搞笑电影。我懂，我真的很幸运。我有幸花了好几年时间在那些电影里演戏，那太有趣了。所以我很怀念那种感觉。是的，过去那种……总会有那么几部。会有那些大型的暑期大片喜剧，而且
were no superheroes in them. And there were no like giant car chases either. There were just like awesome jokes. And now those are exclusively... Exclusively I guess streaming? Theatrical releases or car chases and horror films. And like superheroes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know every you know everything cycles It does it does I was I was listening to I listed this podcast this film history show called you must remember this do you know the show no no But I'm writing it down very good. You know it'll just give you like a reminder of like how You know like the parallels between like in the 50s when television came along
里面没有超级英雄。里面也没有什么巨大的汽车追逐戏。只有超棒的笑话。而现在那些东西成了独家……我想独家在流媒体上播放？院线发行的都是汽车追逐和恐怖片。还有超级英雄。对。对。对。对，我不知道，每样东西都有它的循环周期。确实如此。我当时在听……我听过一个播客，一个叫做《你必须记住这个》的电影历史节目，你知道这个节目吗？不，不知道。但我正在记下来。非常棒。你知道的，它会让你回想起，你知道的，比如上世纪50年代电视出现时，
and the studios were collapsing. There's a lot of parallels between that and now. It just is a reminder that everything cycles. Well, what will happen is someone will make a great comedy. It'll be an outlier and it'll hit big and then we'll go into the season of comedy again. I think we're doing something like that Yeah, I think we're due for like a whole new group of people a whole new like style account like, you know Cuz it kind of felt like you know
制片厂濒临崩溃的那些平行相似之处。现在的情况和当时有很多相似之处。它只是提醒人们，万物皆有周期。好吧，接下来会发生的事情是，会有人拍出一部伟大的喜剧。它会是一个特例，然后大获成功，接着我们就会再次迎来喜剧的季节。我觉得我们现在正在做类似的事情。是的，我觉得我们该迎来全新的一群人了，一种全新的喜剧风格，你知道的，因为感觉就像，你知道的
like I had like like one line in like super bad and it was like It feels like everyone in super bad got a career It felt like that was like a graduating class a little bit, you know And we're all still kind of still around. And I don't know like what the equivalent movie to that since then is. Like it felt like there was like a scene like UCB and like I don't know. Because I feel like it's like you said you've been around long enough, you know, like I feel like I still know and see like everybody from you know 20 years ago that whatever that was. I still like hang out
就像我在《超级坏》里只有一句台词，当时感觉就像……感觉《超级坏》里的每个人都闯出了一片星途。感觉就像那是毕业班的一届学生，你知道的，而且我们大家现在都还在演艺圈里。我不知道自那以后还有哪部电影能与之对等。感觉当时就像有一个场景，比如UCB（正直公民剧团）之类的。因为我觉得就像你说的，你在这个圈子待得够久了，你知道的，就像我觉得我依然认识并能看到20年前的每一个人，无论当年那是怎样的一群人。我依然喜欢和
with my friends from Improv Olympic. So it's like that group you kind of come up together with. All right, Clark, it is time for our call sheet questions. Okay. What was your first entertainment job that you were paid for? I believe it was a commercial when I was like five or six years old.
我在即兴奥林匹克认识的朋友们一起玩。所以这就是那种你一起成长起来的群体。好吧，克拉克，现在是我们的通告单问答时间。好的。你拿到的第一份有报酬的娱乐工作是什么？我想大概是一个广告吧，我当时大概五六岁。
Come on. It was either a commercial or it was, I did a pilot that Carrie Fisher wrote and produced and Debbie Reynolds starred in. What? When I was like six years old. Were you a child actor? Yes, yes.
得了吧。要么是一个广告，要么是我参演了一部由凯莉·费雪编剧并制作、黛比·雷诺斯主演的试播集。什么？我当时大约六岁。你是个童星？对，是的。
What? I did not know this, did you know this? I did not know this. Yes. First of all, I need to back it up. My SAG card says like 1991 on it. Okay, wait. Yeah, that's not know this. Did you know this? I did not know this. First of all, I need to back it up. My SAG card says like 1991 on it. Okay, wait. Yeah. That's not a joke.
什么？我不知道这事，你知道吗？我不知道这事。是的。首先，我得倒带一下。我的演员工会（SAG）卡上写着大约是1991年。好吧，等等。是的，这不是玩笑。
Okay. I need to- Member since 1991. I need you to back up. That's the year I graduated from high school. Yeah, well I was already, I already had a full-time job. You did? So. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
好吧。我需要——1991年入会。我需要你倒带一下。那是我高中毕业的年份。对，好吧，我当时已经，我当时已经有一份全职工作了。你有了？所以。等等，等等，等等，等等。
Wait, I need to know. I have so many questions now. You were living in Arkansas, and you became a child actor in Arkansas. No. No. My mother had a childhood friend live in LA that we came and visited that was working as an actress. Okay.
等等，我得知道。我现在有太多的问题了。你当时住在阿肯色州，然后你在阿肯色州成了一个童星。没有。没有。我妈妈有个儿时好友住在洛杉矶，我们去拜访过她，她当时是一名女演员。好吧。
And her manager saw me. It was like, this kid's gotta be in showbiz. We gotta get this kid out, we gotta send him out. And like sent me on, I think a commercial, I mean my mother can answer this better than I could because I was like five years old. But yeah, booked a bunch of commercials and then did- Do you remember then any of the commercials?
然后她的经纪人看到了我。就觉得，这小孩得进娱乐圈。我们得把这小孩弄出去，我们得把他送去。然后就让我去面试，我想是一个广告吧，我的妈妈能比我回答得更好，因为我当时大概五岁。但没错，接拍了一堆广告，然后做了——你还记得那些广告吗？
Like what were the products? Like Toyota, Kellogg's, there was a Pop Tarts and there were all like big national spots. Wow. Yeah, did that pilot and then CBS signed me to a holding deal. How old were you when you had a holding deal? Like six or seven, like something like that. How was that for you? Did you? It was fun. Like there was no pressure. There was no pressure. You're a child. Yeah. Yeah. Because I was I was a very like gregarious, you know, like, like talkative, like. But would you have to leave school to do these projects? And how was that socially? You were like the guy who was going to LA from Arkansas? Yeah, but I mean, you're like such a little kid.
比如都是些什么产品？比如丰田、家乐氏，有一个是Pop Tarts（宝塔卷/夹心脆饼），全都是那种全国性的大广告。哇。是的，拍了那个试播集，然后CBS（哥伦比亚广播公司）跟我签了一份长期保留合约（holding deal）。你拥有保留合约的时候几岁？大概六七岁，差不多那个年纪。你觉得那段经历怎么样？你有？挺好玩的。就觉得没有什么压力。没有什么压力。你当时是个孩子。是的。是的。因为我当时是一个非常社交，你知道的，就像，非常健谈，就像——但你拍这些项目需要请假离开学校吗？这在社交方面怎么样？你就像那个从阿肯色州去洛杉矶的小伙子？对，但我的意思是你还只是个小孩子。
I feel like it's before you're like... That's true. It's before anyone's really aware of it. It's before neurotic stuff sets in. Yeah, they're just like, Clark's back. Okay, hi, Clark. And then I ended up on um on the sitcom Called hearts of fire. This is John Ritter and Markie Post and Billy Bob Thornton and Ed Asner
我觉得那是在你——确实如此。那是大家真正意识到这一点之前。那是神经质的心态开始作祟之前。是的，大家只会说，克拉克回来了。噢，嗨，克拉克。然后我最终参演了一部名叫《火热的心》的情景喜剧。里面有约翰·里特、玛基·波斯特、比利·鲍伯·松顿和艾德·阿斯纳
Crazy cast and Billy Bob's also from Arkansas as most people probably know like the same place that I'm from and Did that for like three years and then after that, went back to school in Arkansas, because my mom, you know, wanted me to have a normal like school and childhood experience. And it was like she was insistent that I like go to school and go to college and all that stuff. So then, yeah, went through high school in Arkansas and then came back out here for college. Okay, wait. And then started working again. I have a question. So when you go back to school in Arkansas, do you still have that acting bug?
这演员阵容太疯狂了，而且比利·鲍伯也是阿肯色州人，正如大多数人可能知道的那样，和我来自同一个地方。我拍那个拍了大约三年，然后在那之后，回阿肯色州继续上学，因为我妈妈（你知道的）希望我能有一个正常学校和童年的体验。她坚持要我去上学、去上大学以及所有那些事情。所以然后，是的，在阿肯色州读完了高中，接着又回到这里上大学。好吧，等等。然后又开始工作了。我有个问题。所以当你回到阿肯色州上学时，你身上还有那种表演的冲动吗？
Like are you doing theater in high school? Are you doing the plays? I wasn't I did very much have like I knew I wanted to come back But I but I since I was about 12, I want I really I really wanted to be a movie director That was really what I always wanted to do and yeah Of course that was from you know being out here like because those were like, like thank God, like I don't have any like child actor horror stories. Like those were like really fun years for me. Like when I think back about like childhood and stuff like that, I have just like really fond,
比如你在高中里演戏剧吗？你参加戏剧社吗？我没有。我确实非常清楚地知道我想回来，但自从我大约12岁起，我就想，我真的、真的非常想成为一名电影导演。那才是我一直真正想做的事情，并且，是的，当然，那来自于（你知道的）在这里的经历，因为那些是（你知道的，谢天谢地）我没有任何童星的恐怖故事。那些对我来说真的是非常快乐的岁月。每当我回想起童年之类的事情，我都只有非常美好、
you know, kind of bizarre memories. Oh man. That's so fascinating to me. So that was, yeah, that was one of my many lives I've lived. I mean, question number one. I know. Mind some goals there. Question number two, do you speak any other languages?
（你知道的）有点离奇的回忆。天哪。这对我来说太迷人了。所以那是，是的，那是我经历过的许多人生中的其中一段。我的意思是，问题一。我懂。那里有一些目标。问题二，你会说其他语言吗？
No. No. I wish. You can move on quickly on question number two. I took Spanish in high school and college, but it's like if you don't use it, you forget it. And I wish. Yeah.
不。不会。希望我会。你可以迅速跳过第二个问题。我在高中和大学里学过西班牙语，但这就跟如果你不用它，就会忘掉一样。我希望我会。是的。
Well, do you play a musical instrument? I can play guitar. Not like excellently or anything, but yeah, play guitar. Right. I had a phase when I lived in the building across the street, we DJed for a while, which was fun. I guess DJing is a type of instrument. It really was.
好吧，你会演奏乐器吗？我会弹吉他。虽然弹得不是特别好，但会弹吉他。对。我曾经有一段时间，当我住在街对面的那栋大楼里时，我们当过一段时间的DJ，那挺有趣的。我想打碟也是一种乐器吧。确实是的。
I mean, it was in the like, it was the last time there was kind of a real scene. It was right before like camera phones basically. Did you have a DJ name? Yeah actually me and my friend Chris Holmes who's still a huge DJ. He's a Paul McCartney's opening act. Oh my gosh. But we uh, we called ourselves Show Business. I thought that was pretty good. Business with an S or a Z? With an S. With an S. Show business taking the stage. We had a, Chris made business cards one time and they said show business
我的意思是，那是在……那是某种真正的现场音乐场景存在的最后一段时期。那基本上是在手机摄像头普及之前。你当时有DJ艺名吗？其实我和我的朋友克里斯·霍姆斯，他现在依然是个超级大DJ。他是保罗·麦卡特尼的开场表演嘉宾。哦，天哪。但我们——我们管自己叫“展翅高飞（Show Business）”。我觉得这个名字挺不错的。Business是用S还是Z？用S。用S。Show business闪亮登场。我们有一次——克里斯印了名片，上面写着Show business，
and then on the back it just said no requests. I thought that was funny. With no contact info either. Just that. Just that. Just that. What's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved?
然后在背面只写了四个字：拒绝点歌。我觉得这挺搞笑的。而且上面没有任何联系方式。只有这个。只有这个。只有这个。有什么地方是你去过之后绝对爱上的吗？
I mean, I've been a lot of places I liked. I really enjoyed getting to film in London, just because the, and getting to like live there for like an extended period, because I did all the touristy stuff, like the walking tours and all that, you know, like the Jack the Ripper historical walking tour, like I did all like with the group,
我的意思是，我去过很多我喜欢的地方。我真的很享受能在伦敦拍电影的经历，仅仅因为……而且还能在那里住上一段时间，因为我做了所有游客会做的事，比如徒步导览之类的（你知道的），比如开膛手杰克的历史徒步之旅，我全都是跟团一起去的，
it's like me and the other group walking around with a little map. So that was pretty fun, because I mean, it's one thing, visit somewhere but to get to kind of live somewhere for a while. You know what was bizarre about that? When I left that season the office to do Kickass 2, that was in London and I was living at these furnished apartments like the Oakwood.
就像我和其他人在拿着小地图到处走。所以那挺有趣的，因为我的意思是，去某个地方旅游是一回事，但能在一个地方生活上一段时间又是另一回事。你知道关于那件事最离奇的是什么吗Q？当我离开那一季的《办公室》去拍《海扁王2》时，那是在伦敦，我住在那些带家具的公寓里，比如橡树公寓（Oakwood）。
I don't know if people know what the Oakwood is. Well it's not even the Oakwood anymore. But you know what I mean. Yeah, it's just furnished apartments that a lot of people stay in when they're filming. Corporate housing. Yeah. Corporate housing. It's not even the Oakwood anymore, but you know what I mean. It's just furnished apartments that a lot of people stay in when they're filming. Corporate housing. And the only other person that I ever saw every day in the gym or the lobby was John Malkovich.
我不知道大家知不知道橡树公寓是什么。好吧，它现在甚至都不叫橡树公寓了。但你知道我的意思。对，就是那种很多人在拍戏时会住的带家具的公寓。企业公寓（Corporate housing）。对。企业公寓。它现在甚至都不叫橡树公寓了，但你知道我的意思。就是很多人在拍戏时会住的带家具公寓。企业公寓。而在健身房或大厅里，我每天唯一能看到的另一个人就是约翰·马尔科维奇。
And we never spoke. How wild. I think I said hello to him. I'm pretty sure I told him this because that was years before I worked with him in Arkansas. But yeah, getting to spend a lot of time in London was really fun. Because I hate long flights, so I don't know if I'll... Like, I'm not somebody that travels for fun, because a 12-hour flight is my nightmare.
而且我们从来没说过话。多么疯狂啊。我想我跟他说过你好。我几乎可以肯定我跟他说过这个，因为那是许多年前我在阿肯色州和他合作之前的事了。不过，是的，能花很多时间在伦敦真的很开心。因为我讨厌长途飞行，所以我不知道我以后会不会……比如，我不是那种为了好玩而旅行的人，因为12小时的飞行简直是我的噩梦。
And I feel like I spent so many years traveling for work a lot. Which was great, because you get to see a lot of places. You get to work in Miami and Atlanta and Vancouver and Toronto and London. I don't know when the next time I'll get back over there is. So I'm happy that I got to, that someone paid me to go on an extended vacation over there was pretty good. It's such a special place. Jenna lived there too for a job. I did. And it's one of my favorite memories too. Cause it's like you said, I really-
而且我觉得我花了好多年时间经常为了工作而出差。这其实挺棒的，因为你能看到很多地方。你能在迈阿密、亚特兰大、温哥华、多伦多和伦敦工作。我不知道我下一次去那边是什么时候了。所以我很高兴我能去，有人付钱让我去那里度了一个超长假，这感觉相当不错。那是一个如此特别的地方。珍娜也曾为工作在那里住过。我住过。这也是我最美好的回忆之一。因为就像你说的，我真的——
The city's like 2000 years old. It's just cool. I mean, amazing. And also there's little things about like, I do love to travel, but I like to stay places as long as possible so I can do things like, what's their grocery store like? No, totally. I agree. You know, like how do they sell their fruit here? I love details like that. The day to day. I remember, Joa left me a message one time while she was over there, we would leave each other messages and she was like,
这座城市有大约2000年的历史了。太酷了。我的意思是，太惊艳了。而且还有一些小细节，比如，我确实喜欢旅行，但我喜欢在一个地方待尽可能长的时间，这样我就可以做一些事情，比如，他们的杂货店是什么样的？完全同意。我赞同。你知道的，他们这里的员工是怎么卖水果的？我喜欢这样的细节。日常生活。我记得，有一次乔安（Joa）在那边的时候给我留了一条留言，我们会互相留言，她当时说，
well, today I went to buy a microwave. Yeah. And you had it, like, was it a book? Well, it was very strange. I had to purchase a microwave for the flat that I was renting and the store, you walked in and there was just a guy behind the counter and then there were like three catalogs.
嗯，今天我去买了一个微波炉。是的。而你当时，就像，那是一本书吗？嗯，这非常奇怪。我必须为我租的公寓买一个微波炉，而那家店，你走进去，柜台后面只有一个伙计，然后有大概三个产品目录。
There weren't items out. No items, and then you would point to it, and he would go like deep in the back, bowels of beyond this door behind the counter, and then he would come back with the microwave. It was like- It's like when you order food and they have the picture. Yes. Yes.
没有展出的实物。没有实物，然后你指着目录上的某款，他就会走进柜台后面那扇门后面的深处、未知的深处，然后他会拿着微波炉走回来。这就好像——这就像你点外卖时看到有图片一样。对。是的。
Or if like Amazon was a store. Was just a dude. And you just like pointed and then they brought it out to you. It was so interesting. And that was when I asked the production, where does one go to buy, how do you buy a microwave here?
或者就像亚马逊变成了一家实体店。就只是一个老兄。然后你指了一下，他们就把东西拿出来给你。太有趣了。而那正是我问剧组制作人员的时候，人在哪里买微波炉，你在这里怎么买微波炉？
They're like, oh, you go to this. Catalog man. Yeah, catalog man. She left me that message years ago. I think about it all the time. I don't know why, but it really stuck with me. Well, another thing was they don't do drip coffee, like a drip coffee maker,
他们说，哦，你去这个。目录男。是的，目录男。她好几年前给我留了那条语音留言。我一直都在想这件事。我不知道为什么，但这真的深深印在了我的脑海里。好吧，还有一件事是，他们不做滴滤咖啡，那种滴滤咖啡机，
where you just make like 12 cups of coffee at once. And I wanted one and I asked them, where does one get a drip coffee maker? Catalog guy didn't know what I was talking about. Everybody was like, what is this machine you speak of? Cause they just do like pour over French press. They make one great cup of coffee in the morning. And then they drink their tea.
就是你一次性能做12杯咖啡的那种。而我想要一个，我问他们，在哪儿能买到滴滤咖啡机？目录男根本不知道我在说什么。所有人都觉得，你在说什么机器？因为他们只做手冲（pour over）或法压壶。他们早上会做一杯极棒的咖啡。然后他们就喝茶。
And you're like, I need 12 cups. I'm like, I know I'm like, want to make 12 at a time. I'm American. I want a thermos of coffee. Yes, I want tons of coffee all the time. So they had assigned me a driver for the show and they said he could also help me get settled. And I remember one day, I'll never forget it.
而你会觉得，我需要12杯。我就像，我心想，我想一次做12杯。我是美国人。我想要一保温瓶的咖啡。是的，我随时都想要巨量的咖啡。所以他们给我为这部剧安排了一个司机，他们说他也可以帮我安顿下来。我记得有一天，我永远不会忘记。
Oh man, I love this guy so much. He pulled up and he had the big smile on his face and he was holding a drip coffee maker in a box because that was the other thing, like it has to have the right plug, you know? It has to go in their outlet so I couldn't just bring mine. I guess I could have done a converter but then, I don't know, I was worried I'm gonna start a fire. So I, so he found one, he found one and when we got to set,
天哪，我太喜欢这家伙了。他把车开过来，脸上带着灿烂的笑容，手里拿着一个装在盒子里的滴滤咖啡机，因为还有一件事，就是它必须有正确的插头，你知道的？它必须能插进他们的电源插座里，所以我不能直接把我自己的带过去。我想我本来可以用一个转换器，但接着，我不知道，我担心我会引发一场火灾。所以，所以他找到了一个，他找到了一个，当我们到达片场时，
he was so excited, He read the directions. He set it up in my trailer. I made us a pot of coffee, shared a cup of coffee with him. He was like, he'd never seen it before. He's like, this was $1,200. This coffee maker. I drove five hours to get it. It was also, you guys, it was also red. It was red. It was like shiny red KitchenAid mixer, but it was a drip coffee maker. And how happy were you to have it?
他兴奋极了。他阅读了说明书。他在我的化妆车里把它装好了。我给我们俩煮了一壶咖啡，和他一起分享了一杯咖啡。他当时说——他以前从未见过这东西。他说：“这个要1200美元。这个咖啡机。我开了五个小时的车才把它买回来。”而且还有，各位，它还是红色的。它是红色的。它就像一个亮红色的KitchenAid（厨房世家）搅拌机，但它是一个滴滤咖啡机。你当时有多开心？
So happy to have it. Do you still have it? I don't because when the show ended, they took all the things that I had bought for my apartment and they put it in storage for me and then the show got canceled and they said what do you want us to do with all this stuff? And it was like well they had given me a budget to buy most of it so I thought well I don't need it and they said well
太开心能拥有它了。你现在还留着它吗？我没有，因为当剧集结束时，他们把我为公寓买的所有东西都收走并帮我放进仓库里了，然后这部剧被砍了，他们问我，你想让我们怎么处理这些东西？当时觉得，嗯，他们给了我预算来买大部分东西，所以我想，我其实不需要这些。他们就说，嗯，
what we could do is we could put it out. We could just let the crew take whatever they want. And I said, that's fine, but you need to give my driver two things before you put everything out. One is that coffee maker. I just want him to have it. Oh, that's nice. And also the TV that I bought, because he carried it up four flights of stairs for me.
我们可以做的是，把它们摆出来。我们可以让剧组人员随便拿他们想要的东西。我说，这没问题，但在你们把所有东西摆出来之前，你们得给我司机两样东西。第一样就是那个咖啡机。我就是想让他拥有它。哦，太暖心了。还有我买的那台电视，因为他帮我把它扛上了四楼。
So he gets both those things, and then everybody can have anything else. I bet every time people come over to his house and they see the TV, he's like, you know whose TV that is, right? Maybe. Like John Voight Spencil on Seinfeld, you know? Yeah.
所以他拿走了这两样东西，然后其他人可以拿走任何其他东西。我敢打赌，每次有人去他家看到那台电视时，他都会说：“你知道那是谁的电视吗，对吧？”也许吧。就像《宋飞正传》里约翰·沃伊特的铅笔一样，你知道吗？对。
This is like somebody, like that show, that other show, Me and J. Cron, I'm Dying Up Here, Robert Forster. The, Robert Forster. The great Robert Forster. I had the pleasure of knowing him. Oh, then you probably have this also. He gave us all letter openers. Do you have the Robert Forster letter opener?
这就像某个人，就像那部剧，另一部剧，我和J·克伦，我正在死里逃生（I'm Dying Up Here），罗伯特·福斯特。那位，罗伯特·福斯特。伟大的罗伯特·福斯特。我有幸认识他。哦，那你们可能也有这个。他给了我们所有的人信纸拆信刀。你有罗伯特·福斯特的拆信刀吗？
No, I never worked with him. I knew him like as a friend. He would come, he and I would both lecture to acting students and he had this great spiel that he would do. And so that's I knew him through a mutual friend and we would speak to aspiring actors and he is a gem. He was awesome. Great story. Jackie Brown is one of my favorite movies.
没有，我从来没跟他合作过。我跟他只是朋友关系。他会来——我和他都会去给表演系学生做讲座，他有一套很棒的即兴演讲。所以这就是我通过共同的朋友认识他的原因，我们会对有抱负的演员发表演讲，他绝对是个宝藏。他太棒了。很棒的故事。杰基·布朗是我最喜欢的电影之一。
Same. Yeah. And you have the letter. He gave us each, each of the cast members, he gave us each a, this nice little box and you open it up as this beautiful silver letter opener. And I use this thing every day. Yeah. And every time I see it, I start, and if anybody ever sees it,
我也是。是的。而且你拥有那把信纸刀。他送给我们每个人——每一位演员，他都送给我们每个人一个这个漂亮的精致小盒子，你打开它，里面是一把精美的银质信纸刀。我每天都在用这东西。是的。每次我看到它，我就会开始，而且如果任何人看到它，
I tell them, you know, it's Robert Forster's letter opener. It's like, it's like John Boyd's pencil in George's car. Totally. But apparently he gave these to literally, I mean, he said this, he's like, I give these to everyone that I work with. So like I've met other people that like worked with them and they're like, oh yeah, I got the letter opener. It's like his thing. It was his thing. He had this guy. That's classy. I want to get a thing. Is it too late? Is it too late? I want to get a thing too.
我都会告诉他们，你知道的，这是罗伯特·福斯特的信纸刀。这就像，这就像约翰·沃伊特的铅笔在乔治的车里一样。完全一样。但显然他把这些送给了字面意义上的——我的意思是，他是这么说的，他说：“我把我合作过的每个人都送一遍。”所以，比如我遇到过其他和他合作过的人，他们会说：“哦，对，我也有那把信纸刀。”这是他的标志性作风。这就是他的特色。他有这一招。真有品位。我也想弄一个标志性的纪念物。现在太晚了吗？现在太晚了吗？我也想弄一个标志性的东西。
I know, I want a thing too. It's so classy. I just turned 50 and I think 50 is when you get a thing that you then do, because otherwise it might be, it might be condescending if you're like 23 and you're like, here's your gift for working with me. Right? That's pretty ballsy though. Once you're older, you can hand out a thing.
我知道，我也想弄一个。这太有品位了。我刚刚50岁了，我觉得50岁就是你会开始弄一个属于自己的标志性物件并一直送下去的年纪，因为否则的话，如果你才23岁，然后你说“这是你跟我合作的礼物”，这可能会显得有点居高临下，对吧？不过那也挺有种的。一旦你上了年纪，你就可以开始发放专属物件了。
Oh, totally, yeah. After they work with you. Oh, I'm starting that. I don't know what I'm giving away but I'm gonna start it. I want to do it with you. I thought we have to do different things though. Yeah we'll come up with something. Yeah I don't know what it should be but I thought the letter opener was such a like classy thing because it's you know it looks nice it's silver it's beautiful and it's so functional. Yeah. You use well I mean I'm saying it's so functional like the kids watching the TikTok are not opening
哦，完全是的，是的。在他们跟你合作之后。哦，我要开始这么做了。我不知道我要送出去什么，但我要开始搞这个。我想跟你一起做。不过我觉得我们得送不同的东西。对，我们会想出点什么的。是的，我不知道应该是什么，但我觉得拆信刀真的是一个很有品位的东西，因为它（你知道的）看起来很好看，是银的，很漂亮，而且非常实用。是的。你用——我的意思是，我说它非常实用，但那些看TikTok的孩子们根本不拆
letters but they'll get bills. They don't know what paper mail is. They don't know what paper mail is, yeah. Again, for the listeners, this is Clark, I am 75 years old. And that means Jenna and I are dot, dot, dot. Okay, we have two more call sheet questions for you. Here they are.
信件，不过他们会收到账单。他们根本不知道什么是纸质邮件。他们根本不知道什么是纸质邮件，是的。再说一遍，各位听众，我是克拉克，我今年75岁了。这意味着珍娜和我——点、点、点。好吧，我们还有两个通告单问题要问你。它们在这里。
Number four, what do you like to do on the weekends? I don't know that my weekend activities that much different from my weekday activity because I don't have like a nine to five, you know? Yeah. Like I like to go to the comic store. Like with the comic book store and you physically hold all the comic books.
第四个问题，你周末喜欢做什么？我不知道我的周末活动和工作日活动有什么太大区别，因为我没有那种朝九晚五的工作，你知道的？是的。比如我喜欢去漫画店。就像去漫画书店，亲手拿着所有的漫画书。
I love that I used to be into comics. I like to go to the comic store rummage around. Yeah. Do you have one that's like your favorite store? My favorite is House of Secrets in Burbank. That's my favorite one. And it's partially my favorite because I literally went there as a child when I was a child actor. So it's got, you know, the nice nostalgia for me. Plus it's also just an excellently ran store Guys that run under are very nice. What's your favorite series? All-time like uncanny x-men like the prime like 1980s Chris Claremont uncanny x-men
我太喜欢了，我以前超级迷漫画。我喜欢去漫画店到处搜寻。是的。你有什么特别最喜欢的店吗？我最喜欢的是伯班克的“秘密之屋（House of Secrets）”。那是我的最爱。它部分成为我的最爱是因为我小时候真的去过那里，当我还是个童星的时候。所以它对我来说（你知道的）有着美好的怀旧情怀。再加上它本身也是一家经营得极好的店，经营这家店的人非常nice。你最喜欢的系列是什么？历史最佳的话，比如《非凡X战警》，黄金时期的那种——20世纪80年代克里斯·克莱蒙特的《非凡X战警》
That's that's pretty tough to beat. I think that's like a seminal thing for like so many like Creative people my age like that and Watchmen yeah those are those are the two I feel like those are the two biggest like because like like the old you know the 80s X-Men I think is basically like the template of kind of like what like Buffy the Vampire Slayer was like that kind of formula like I feel like it kind of went out and had a much bigger you know impact than people realize did you ever get get into the comedic,
那个真的很难被超越。我觉得那是许多像我这个年纪的创意工作者的一部开创性作品，比如那个和《守望者》——是的，这两个是我觉得最大的两部，因为就像（你知道的）老版80年代的《X战警》，我觉得它基本上就是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》这类作品的模板，那种模式——我觉得它最终产生的影响比人们意识到的要大得多。你有没有接触过那种喜剧风格的、
autobiographical comics? Yeah, like Arkrum and Peter Panhagen, that kind of stuff. Or like Joe Matt or whoever. Yeah, totally, totally. But I mean, for me, the childhood thing was definitely like the X-Men and the Spider-Man and the superhero stuff. But no, there's really great work being done now in comics yeah all right final question Angela all right
自传性质的漫画？对，比如阿克姆（Artb Spiegelman）和皮特·帕汉姆（Peter Bagge）那一类的。或者像乔·马特（Joe Matt）之类的。对，完全是，完全是。但对我来说，童年时期看的东西绝对是《X战警》、《蜘蛛侠》和超级英雄之类的东西。不过不，现在漫画里真的有很多非常棒的作品。好，最后一个问题，安吉拉。好的。
Clark what is your favorite midnight snack? ooh I think my favorite midnight snack is probably it's either fruity pebbles or the cocoa pebbles you like a little cereal a little cereal and I specifically like those two. I like the Post brand cereals. Did you do commercials for them? No. Oh no.
克拉克，你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？哦，我想我最喜欢的午夜零食可能是——要么是水果圈（Fruity Pebbles），要么是可可圈（Cocoa Pebbles）。你喜欢来点麦片，来点麦片。而且我特指这两种。我喜欢Post品牌的麦片。你给它们拍过广告吗？没有。哦，不。
No, just Kellogg's. But I love the two Flintstones branded cereals. Milk. The Rice Krispie versions are good too, the Cocoa Krispies are also good. Oh yeah, I do full milk. They're fantastic, yeah. This is another, I am 75 years old, I still buy milk, like regular milk. do full milk. This is another like, I am 75 years old,
没有，只有家乐氏。但我超爱那两款以摩登原始人（Flintstones）为品牌的麦片。牛奶。谷脆小饼（Rice Krispies）的版本也不错，可可脆（Cocoa Krispies）也挺好的。哦，对，我用的是全脂牛奶。它们棒极了，是的。这是另一个——我今年75岁了，我依然买牛奶，就像普通牛奶那种。用全脂牛奶。这是另一个——我今年75岁了，
I still buy milk, like regular milk. No fancy milk. No, none of these fake milks. Give me the real deal. Full f***ing milk. I see a milk commercial in your future. Not even like 2%, I want the whole. The whole, yeah.
我依然买牛奶，就像普通牛奶那种。不要什么花里胡哨的奶。不，不要任何这些假牛奶。给我来真的。他妈的全脂牛奶。我仿佛看到未来有一个牛奶广告在向你招手。甚至不是2%脱脂的，我要全脂的。全脂的，是的。
Well Clark, thank you so much. Thank you guys. Thank you. It's so nice to see you. Come and buy it, hanging out with us today. This was a pleasure. Yeah. Thank you. It's so nice to see you. Come and buy it. Hanging out with us today. This was a pleasure. Yeah.
好吧，克拉克，非常感谢你。谢谢你们。谢谢。很高兴见到你。欢迎常来，今天和我们一起聊天真是太愉快了。是的。谢谢。很高兴见到你。欢迎常来。今天和我们一起聊天真是太愉快了。是的。
This is super fun. So wonderful to see you. By the way, your email that you sent back, oh my God, this is great. This is so funny. Wait, we have to tell. Yeah, I should tell this. So when I was, when my first movie, Arkansas, the first movie I directed was coming out, it was in the midst of all the COVID stuff.
这超级有趣。见到你太棒了。顺便说一句，你回的那封邮件，哦天哪，这太棒了。这太搞笑了。等等，我们得告诉大家。是的，我应该讲讲这个。所以当我在——我的第一部电影《阿肯色》，我执导的第一部电影即将上映时，那正处于各种新冠疫情的混乱之中。
And so I texted and emailed all the people I knew that had big Instagram or social media following. So I was like, hey, I'm just trying to get the word out, people who watch this movie. And I sent this email, I sent it to you, amongst a bunch of other people I know. And you emailed me, you responded to the email like a month ago? Yeah.
所以我在Instagram或社交媒体上粉丝量很大的所有人中给他们发了短信和邮件。所以我当时就想，嘿，我只是想把消息传出去，让大家来看这部电影。我发了这封邮件，我把它发给了你，还有我认识的其他许多人。而你给我回了邮件——你是在大概一个月前回复的邮件？是的。
And the emails from- No, like two months ago. The emails from 2020. 2020. Yeah. And I went, I was like looking for your email. God, I don't know, maybe to my spam or whatever. But I was like, oh my God, Clark. I go, this is great about your movie.
而且那封邮件来自——不，大概是两个月前。那封邮件来自2020年。2020年。是的。我当时去找你的邮件。天哪，我不知道，也许是在我的垃圾邮件里或者别的什么地方。但我就想，哦天哪，克拉克。我说，关于你的电影，这消息太棒了。
It's so sorry I missed it. And then I was like, do you want to come on the podcast? I'm so sorry. And this is like one of the things Jenna knows, And then I was like, do you want to come on the podcast? I'm so sorry. And this is like one of the things Jenna knows, like Sam and Cassie, they all know that my inbox, unusual, says about, I don't know what's it say today, 3,814.
很抱歉我错过了。然后我就想，你想不想来上播客？非常抱歉。而这就是珍娜知道的事情之一，就像萨姆和卡西，他们都知道我的收件箱里不寻常地显示着，我不知道今天显示多少，3814封。
Oh, that physically hurt me just now. I know. I have to zero mine out. I do as well. I have to have it, I have to zero it. I cannot. That would give me... I have whittled that down. You would not believe. I wouldn't be able to function. What's in there? Is it just like from like Michaels? Like $5 coupons from Michaels and home goods and stuff? Exactly. Yes. And I need to go through it. But anyway,
哦，我刚刚听到这个数字时心头一紧。我知道。我得把我的收件箱清零。我也是。我必须得，我必须把它清空。我不能——那会让我——我已经把那个数字削减下来了。你绝对不敢相信。我简直无法正常生活。里面都是些什么？难道全都是来自迈克尔工艺品店（Michaels）的邮件吗？就像来自迈克尔工艺品店的5美元优惠券和家居用品之类的东西？完全正确。是的。我需要去清理一下。不过无论如何，
so I missed your email. But now I've put little. But the fact that you did, the funny thing is you didn't send a new email. You responded to that one. That was what I love. Clark, so sorry, I missed this. Oh my God. I was doing like, I was trying to open up emails I hadn't opened up. I know, it was so ridiculous.
所以我错过了你的邮件。但现在我已经把它们放进小——但有趣的是你并没有发一封新邮件。你是直接回复了那封旧邮件。这就是我最喜欢的地方。克拉克，太抱歉了，我错过了这个。哦天哪。我当时在做的是——我试图打开我以前没打开过的邮件。我知道，这太荒谬了。
Do you worry you may have missed like other, like way more important emails? I'm sure I have. I'm sure I have. I just have to let it go. It doesn't keep me up at night at all. It keeps me up at night. It bothers Jenna.
你难道不担心自己可能错过其他更重要的邮件吗？我肯定错过过。我肯定错过过。我只能随它去了。这完全不会让我失眠。这会让我失眠。这让珍娜很困扰。
I wouldn't be able to function. In our business partnership over this last five years, Angela has had to create so many strategies to open email. And I've said to her too, I've said like, how do I contact you? Like most reliably. Text me.
我根本无法正常生活。在我们过去五年的商业合作中，安吉拉不得不创造出各种各样的策略来打开邮件。我也对她说过，我曾对她说，我该怎么联系你？最可靠的方式是什么？发短信给我。
Are you better on text? Yes. I'm so much better on text. Noted. But I'll send her an email, but I mean sometimes you can't, an email is necessary for business. So I will send her an email
你发短信更在行吗？是的。我发短信可擅长多了。记下了。但我还是会给她发邮件，不过我的意思是，有时你没办法，做生意发邮件是必须的。所以我会给她发邮件，
and then I will text her and say, I just sent you an email. I'll tell you what you need. You need to get a fax machine. I'd love a fax because I would hear it Like the bat phone This serious, but I have it's either a doctor's office Yeah, either way kids school. Yeah, either way serious I did create all these little folders now and I you can tell the folder what emails to put in it And so I have my business folder
然后我会发短信告诉她，我刚刚给你发了一封邮件。我告诉你你需要什么。你需要弄一台传真机。我很想要一台传真机，因为听到它响起来会像蝙蝠洞的紧急电话一样。这太严肃了，但我有——要么是诊所的传真机，对，要么是孩子们学校的。对，无论如何都很严肃。我现在确实创建了所有这些小文件夹，你可以告诉文件夹把什么邮件放进里面。所以我有一个商务文件夹，
So I that only has like 12 emails since she did that she's been a different person business wise I think you should think about the facts though. I can't say personal email-wise but business-wise. I think you guys should buy two fax machines. One for your house, one for your house. I kind of want to do this. I do too. I would. If you get one, I'll get one. You have to get a landline. I have a landline. It's my passion. You guys, I had a landline and then my husband was like we never use the landline I should get it back. I'm not getting rid of mine. Never. It's like the physical newspaper I'm gonna try to enjoy it as long as we can. I get the physical newspaper Wait, are you Jenna has the landline because she's worried about like a zombie apocalypse and that way she will have a landline Hey, I mean when when the fires hit,
所以里面只有大概12封邮件。自从她这么做之后，她在商业上就像变了个人。我觉得你们应该考虑一下传真机。虽然我不能说个人邮件方面，但在商务方面，我觉得你们俩应该买两台传真机。一台放你家，一台放你家。我有点想这么干。我也是。我真的会。如果你买一台，我也买一台。你得装一根座机电话线。我有座机。那是我的挚爱。各位，我以前有个座机，然后我丈夫说我们从来不用座机，我应该把它弄回来。我是绝对不会扔掉我的座机的。绝不。这就像实体报纸一样，我打算尽我们所能尽可能久地享受它。我订了实体报纸。等等，你是——珍娜留着座机是因为她担心僵尸末日之类的，这样她就还能有一部座机。嘿，我的意思是，当大火袭来时，
the first thing I did was get out my little boop boop boop boop boop boop phone and plug it in the wall. Yep. Because I was like, if I need to alert someone of this exact place, I'm calling 911, and they immediately know your address. Yeah.
我做的第一件事就是拿出我的小嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟电话，把它插到墙上的插孔里。没错。因为我觉得，如果我需要向别人报警这个确切的地点，我就会拨打911，他们能立刻知道你的地址。
Yeah. I don't know. It's basically free with my cable and internet, too I think it's like ten more dollars a month or something Alright, so if we each get a fax machine, I'll fax you guys. Yeah. Oh my god We can send each other like the gag faxes, you know, like the funny drawings. Uh-huh memes basically memes Oh the first name really was that really was the original Yeah, oh, well well this was a delight.
是的。我不知道。而且这跟我的有线电视和网络套餐在一起基本上是免费的，我想大概一个月多十块钱左右吧。好吧，如果我们俩都弄一台传真机，我就发传真给你们。太棒了。我们可以互相发那种恶作剧传真，你知道的，比如搞笑的涂鸦。嗯哼，基本上就是表情包。哦，传真其实真的是最早的表情包。是的，哦，好吧，这次真的太开心了。
Yeah. Clark, thanks so much. Thank you so much. My pleasure. Email me when your movie comes out. Fax her. Text me. I'll just come over here.
是的。克拉克，非常感谢。非常感谢。我的荣幸。你的电影上映时发邮件告诉我。发传真给她。发短信给我。我直接过来。
All right, you know where we are now. Well, that was absolutely amazing. And were we right about the call sheet questions? Clark is so interesting. He's so layered. And were we right about the call sheet questions? Clark is so interesting. He's so layered. Oh my goodness. Well, thank you all for writing in your questions and comments. And thank you, Clark, for coming in the studio today.
好了，你们现在知道我们在哪儿了。好吧，那真是太棒了。我们对通告单问题的看法没错吧？克拉克太有趣了。他太有层次感了。我们对通告单问题的看法没错吧？克拉克太有趣了。他太有层次感了。哦天哪。好吧，非常感谢大家写信来提出你们的问题和评论。也非常感谢克拉克今天来到录音室做客。
Yeah. I am really loving having these sit down one-on-ones with the cast members of the office. Yeah. And getting to reconnect. Yeah. Now we're going to get fax machines. So we're going to be in touch all the time. We hope you guys have a great week.
是的。我真的很喜欢和《办公室》的演员们进行这种面对面的单人访谈。是的。并且重新建立联系。是的。现在我们要去买传真机了。所以我们会一直保持联系。我们希望大家都有个愉快的一周。
See you soon. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
回头见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。